okay
I've got to turn my mic on too
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee uh for the record my name
is Catherine Province I serve as the
chief administrative officer and vice
Chancellor of Finance for our state's
University system
when uh president Dean and I were last
here
House Bill 2 had not yet been issued we
briefly talked about a couple of
sections that the governor had mentioned
in house bill 2. one related to an
appropriation for the Whittemore Center
at UNH and the second an appropriation
for blockchain quality assurance Center
so Allison Rich and Jeff lepac will
introduce themselves and speak to each
of those projects respectively so I'll
turn it over to Allison thanks good
morning everybody I'm Allison Rich I'm
the director of Athletics at the
University of New Hampshire thank you
for having me Senator Representatives I
really appreciate being able to be here
you have two handouts from me which you
can look over at your leisure afterwards
but I wanted to make sure that you had
some photos and some information to take
away with you from today I'll be talking
about the upgrades to the Whittemore
Center as you can see on the front of
the the photo packet we have a picture
of the snively Arena which was the the
former Arena before way to more Center
that was 29 years old when it was
retired we are now looking at the
Whittemore Center which is 28 years old
so there's a lot of our brand new Arena
and it's a wonderful place to play and
we've been working on the ice and and
it's a fantastic place for people to
watch a game but the underneath area has
not been addressed since it was built in
1995 and we're looking at competition in
a very tough league as well as across
the NCAA you'll see that the majority of
teams that we compete against have
either have already completed run
Innovations are in the midst or are
about to begin Renovations and so we're
the one of the last ones left who have
not done that it's hampering our
recruiting efforts and our competitive
efforts because you know everybody's
looking on their phones they're seeing
what everybody else has and they're
seeing these beautiful new facilities
and upgraded facilities that are costing
mostly 50 to 70 million dollars although
I was just at the University of
Connecticut whose facility was an 85
million dollar project and Sacred Heart
has one that's over 80 million dollars
so we're looking to definitely make sure
that we're able to be competitive we're
looking to bring in the strong student
athletes who are looking to compete at a
high level and also succeed academically
and I think that's where we have a
really great selling point at UNH is
that we have the opportunity for our
student athletes to be outstanding both
athletically and academically and in
anything they choose to do which an
opportunity they don't have at many
other institutions however when the
facilities aren't looking so great it's
very appealing to go to another school
and be able to win and and I think that
they can do what they need to do
academically there even if it might not
be quite as as easy so we had
representative Murray and representative
papovichi Mueller as well as Senator
Pearl with us last week on a tour and
we've extended another invitation I
think there's another one coming today
if anybody's interested in in returning
or coming for the first time for a tour
of the facilities to see what we're
looking at there
um just to walk you through very briefly
the the entire project is about a 30
million dollar project it's a
public-private partnership we're excited
about the people that are interested in
in contributing uh to the program this
would be about nine million dollars in
philanthropic donations that we'll be
raising uh then it'll be uh 13 roughly
13 million from the University that
includes some work that's already been
started we shrank the ice surface from
an olympic size ring to one that's more
in line with college standards and NHL
standards replace the the boards and the
glass with much safer and more
up-to-date Alternatives and the sound
system which was delayed a little bit by
uh by supply chain is now on its way in
uh next month so on the boat yes it is
off the boat finally here but it was on
the boat for a while yes so uh so this
is a the overall project about 30
million dollars so this is something
that we want to do the right way so that
we're not back here right away this is
something we want to last for another
hopefully 30 years if possible but this
is something that we think would be a
great Boon to the university as well as
to the state and we look at Athletics as
the front porch of the University which
means that a lot of people first the
first impression of the university and
often of the state since it's a flagship
University is of the Athletics program
and so we do everything we can to try to
bring positive attention to the
university to be that great entry point
for people to see and for people to want
to engage with the university and with
the state and so this project would help
us with bringing in high high level
admissions of high-level students and
student athletes those students who want
to be a part of something really
exciting I hear from many alumni and
many community members of how much they
enjoyed coming to games as as students
and how much they enjoyed being a part
of the the winning tradition that that
was and hopefully will soon be again UNH
hockey it'll attract strong student
athletes who will come to the area from
all over the world and many of our
student athletes do end up staying in
New Hampshire afterwards because they
fall in love with the place and I can
see why as somebody who brand new to the
area I've been there since just the end
of July and they'll stay and it brings
in Revenue to the state we have visitors
who come to the games we will be
bringing in other concerts and outside
events to the arena and be able to do
more than we can do now because we are
updating the support spaces so a concert
can come in and have a green room space
where large name big name acts would
want to sit before their their concert
instead of what's now kind of an open
area with benches and and getting
showers so very quickly just to show you
what I have in the packet and you can
take a look there's some notes
um on the first few pages we included
some some photos this is page five of
some of the updates that have been done
to the strength and conditioning areas
uh some of our our competitors and then
the next page you'll see where we are in
the in the wit on page six and you'll
see that our players do warm up and
stretch in the hallway before games and
this is while the carts are going by
with concessions food and people are
coming in to see the game and the all
the Zamboni drivers are around so it's
it's kind of a crowded area and our
women do the same thing this is a photo
of the men but our women are in the the
same exact situation which also makes
you worry a little bit about some safety
with who's wandering up and down the
hallway the weight room is basically a
room as you can see with a couple of
machines and not large enough for even
part of the team to to participate in
you'll see the next page on page seven
the weight room and and all of that area
right now is across the street at the
field house that's what's available for
all student athletes and so in the snow
in the rain and the wind in the winter
in the summer they are going across the
street after or before their ice time to
then lift weights and do their
conditioning and then come back over
since their locker room is in the
Whittemore Center so sweaty and
um kind of in the middle of going back
and forth for their workouts we don't
hear anything from them about it but we
do know that would be a plus to be in
the same building it would also give us
another space where we can space out the
rest of our teams we do have 20 teams in
a fair really small area in the field
house you can see the next page has the
study areas the mule areas nutrition
areas that some of our competitors and
then on page nine you'll see our one
lone student athlete who's watching the
TV I guess and the table that we put out
before the game with their nutritious
snacks to make sure that they're
properly fueled for the for the game
the following page is the locker room
spaces some of our competitors as well
you'll see there's a theme of kind of
how they're looking now and how
beautiful and well lit they are the next
page you have our women original women's
lockers from 1995 they have not been
updated and then the locker room the
men's room was updated in 2009 with some
private funding which you can't
experience what representative Murray
has experienced is the smell and the air
quality in these facilities part of the
the money that's coming from the
university is to address the HVAC system
because there is almost no air
circulation so you can be literally feet
steps from the ice surface and it's
about 80 degrees and hockey equipment if
you've never experienced it has its own
unique Aroma and so it's it's not a very
pleasant place to be so that's a big
part of this project I'll quickly
because I want to make sure that Jeff
has some time but the training room area
you'll see some of our competitors and
then you'll see the shared athletic
training room in the witch which is
based just a room and the cold tub
that's jammed in between the ice machine
and the the tubs for the or the coolers
for the for the drinks
and then I won't take too much time on
this to propose reconfigured space it
all almost all will be within the
existing footprint we're trying to save
money here and do this very efficiently
and economically the one space that does
go outside is the little box on the top
right and that's a small bump out on the
main level for the strength conditioning
area which will then have a view for the
ice will allow some branding some
corporate sponsorship there and again
bring in a little bit more to support
the project and to support the
university and then you'll see some
proposed renderings of what our spaces
would look like
you can see another picture of when
we've hosted large con concerts in the
past how this ends up looking and it's a
wonderful venue to host these events and
then of course uh the a photo of when we
had white out the wait a couple of weeks
ago or we sold out two two games in a
row for the first time and since 2013 it
was an amazing electric environment it's
a place where people love to play where
people love to watch and we'd like to
get back there at a consistent level
where we have the the student athletes
who can be successful and really bring
some some pride to the university into
the state so I'm happy to answer any
questions that you might have
questions
okay yes
thank you and uh thank you for the tour
it was really really interesting to see
a lot of that and a surprise thing to
see it just as an aside the athletes
limbering up in the hallway I didn't
quite realize when I walked out there
that they were doing that but at least
they were fit and good looking so they
are
um
a concept that came up I think when
y'all were here the first time perhaps
the second time and it was a concept new
to me and I'm still learning about it
and this was the competitive e-gaming
and I'm looking for additional return on
investment sorts of things how else can
this put you out there and the way these
things were being discussed it sounds
like this is something people go to
watch kids play computer games and
there's a lot of money in this with this
arena with with this I know that you
know scheduling with all the different
athletic activities and you know sort of
the events but would this be a possible
arena for an e-gaming competition that
would Elevate UNH and do they bring in
money would they bring in money to the
university
so it certainly could because you're
looking for a center-hung scoreboard
which we have and the the seats and
you're right people do actually come and
watch
um people compete on in video games and
there there's a lot of skill and
strategy involved I've learned a lot
about this over the last few years it's
really interesting but um this would be
a venue that would be appropriate for
that what it would bring in as far as
Revenue would be the rental fee however
we structured it with tickets but
certainly that could be an outside event
that could be hosted there
oh okay
did you ask your competitors how they
funded their facilities
combination just like what we're doing
there's some privately raised funds some
have foundations that are associated
with the universities that that give
quite a bit to the programs others are
private invest a lot of private
investment and some State funding as
well for those who are State
institutions or public institutions
private Investments they expect a return
on their investment
yes so the return on their investment
would be that they'd have a wonderful
Arena where they could come and watch
the game and support
other questions
pretty straightforward yeah I do I do
think you know as far as investment as
well as what I mentioned about the
return that it would bring to the state
and to the university as well
sure
um you have a lot of support you know in
your your Sky Box or those those boxes
that go along the edge there
um
I I don't know how to ask this without
you know being in delicate sort of about
it do they provide a lot of money are
the people who are in those boxes paying
a good chunk of change to be in those
boxes
they do pay and that's part of our our
media rights deal that we have with
learfield so that does bring in money to
support the the program but it's all we
have a level a threshold where we need
to meet what we need to sell as far as
those sponsorships so they are corporate
sponsors who who do Reserve those boxes
yes
another question what thank you very
much thank you and that's the eight
million dollars in a Governor's budget I
believe that's in section 9 of house
bill 2.
um
so uh in the section in section eight is
the million and a half for the
blockchain insurance okay and
um Jeffrey pack can speak to that and
it's kind of the Genesis sport okay
good morning everybody
um I am the director for the
interoperability lab as well as the
coven uh testing facility at the
University uh it's kind of a varied
experience there um I'll give you a
little bit of background on what the
interoperability lab is just to kind of
give you a frame of reference but we are
um what sometimes we refer to ourselves
as spin in rather than a spin out
company
um we are a third party testing facility
that specializes in the data
Communications space so basically
anywhere data is traveling back and
forth we offer some sort of service to
companies who build products there to
validate their equipment make sure that
it works well and is interoperable as in
it works from company a to Company B
it's the high level thing
um we are 100 commercially funded by
those business partners we work with
about 180 global companies in any given
year so we are one of the larger
corporate facing entities inside the
University
um so again we specialize in facing
businesses engaging them bringing them
to the state
um bringing them to the university to
get some sort of value
uh we're also a very large Workforce
Development facility our Workforce is
primarily built of students which is
really why we're still inside the
university rather than being a spin out
um so we have about 120 to 125
undergraduate and graduate employees in
any given year and those are the folks
who are doing the work our staffing
level is about 25 to 30 in any given
year they're supporting the students
doing that training but the students are
engaging these companies they're working
directly with the engineers we have
about a 99.9 placement once they
graduate
so we're constantly turning them over I
lose a quarter of my Workforce every
year which is a crazy way to run a
business but that's what we do
um we are working in about 40 ish
different Technologies at the moment and
we are trying to support some of the
work that's happening here at the State
House in blockchain space basically so
there's already some legislation
committee I think House Bill 645 is
looking at creating a legal status for
uh Dao's decentralized autonomous
organizations
um and this is really an opportunity for
us to have a Kickstart one time only
support from
um the state to basically staff up and
be ready to offer services in this space
and complementary to what you guys are
doing uh in some of the house bills
yeah that the intention is that after
the startup
this Center
will be funded by
um
corporations just as all the companies
that the iol works with now fund that
work it's real again it's a it's a jump
start infusion let's get the center set
up
based on the work of the cryptocurrency
commission and the recommendations
again there's a bill moving through the
the legislative process and then it will
be
funded by external parties uh once it's
up and running
first I want to say congratulations for
the work that UNH was doing with the
lake euron and finding the ship in that
program
um I really am just in awe of the
wonderful stuff that UNH is doing and I
have visited your Center and was so
impressed with the kids because it was
they knew exactly what they were doing
they knew what they were talking about
who were they with whom they were
meeting with
um it was
the best kind of learning that kids
could ever have they were just applying
their knowledge to real life situations
I think this is a spectacular idea
um can you just kind of give me a sense
of um the revenue that you're generating
that keeps you alive sure so we're
currently about eight million dollars in
Revenue in any given year that's
supporting those staff and students were
obviously part of the University so
we're a non-profit which is why an
investment like this is actually very
beneficial we don't
we're not building up a warehouse of
money that we can invest in in new
technology spaces all the time uh and
then blockchain is uh as I think you're
all aware an incredibly large investment
area for businesses right now and so
Staffing in this space is expensive
great thank you and these funds will
give you what you need to develop this
aspect so that you can go out and build
relationships with corporations exactly
who will then sell fund this model
moving forward and our students will be
the ones doing it they will be doing it
going off and running the businesses and
getting wonderful jobs from it correct
thank you very much
thank you Mr chair Mary I was hoping you
would ask my question but using words of
no more than two syllables can you
explain what is blockchain quality
assurance sure so blockchain
um do we need a blockchain background as
well or
just a little bit okay so it's it's a
method for
um having a distributed Ledger system
basically is the easiest way to describe
this where it's decentralizes and
there's not one particular home there's
not you know I don't own The Ledger that
everybody else is coming and writing to
there's a way that everybody can access
it and write to it it has a lot of
utility in a bunch of different business
cases outside of traditional models so
that's kind of a super high level
um introductory to that the quality
assurance piece uh is uh we act as a
third party currently for the
technologies that we work with
um and this would be the same thing in
the blockchain space so companies
building products and building chains in
this space could come to us to get
validation we would then give them back
a report or some sort of certification
that says yes we observed what you did
you're you're actually doing what you
say you're doing there aren't loopholes
or places where attacks could be found
um and providing that Assurance back to
people who are making investments in the
space or evaluating different uh
different opportunities for them to
invest in so that's the quality
assurance piece there's also a huge
number of other opportunities in the
space
um alongside the quality assurance so
I've only heard the phrase blockchain
used with regards to cryptocurrency yes
so is that the world that we're talking
in because you were using you didn't use
that word once I didn't use
cryptocurrency because blockchain is not
just cryptocurrency okay that is
obviously the big utilities where the
exciting money is at the moment
um but this is some a technology that's
actually uh got a whole bunch of other
applications that are very specific to
say you know government
um California right now is running a
parallel
blockchain alongside with their DMV
process where car registrations and
license plates are actually being kept
tracked in two different systems because
they see some utility in moving that
into a blockchain rather than their
existing system so there's a lot of
potential Technologies and business
cases for this outside of cryptocurrency
itself
I have a very stupid question
when you're working with all the
blockchain parties
approximately how many locations do
these 180 clients represent so we at
we're Global we work with companies that
are all across the United States
one client could have 50 locations
correct okay
so you don't really know I think we we
typically are working with one division
inside a company but you know these are
our typical companies you know think
like a Microsoft or an apple they've got
offices
you know spread out everywhere right so
we're typically working with one or two
departments inside an organization of
that scale okay
uh this is a strategic question that a
financial question
you said you you don't have the ability
to hoard cash that's my words uh it
seems like that would be a better idea
I mean we have we have two Enterprise
operations for the state we have the
liquor stores and
I just lost the other one
Lottery yeah
the two and I can't think of one of them
but that that operate autonomously as a
business unit
um
trying to think if they they can't hoard
funds either can they
we take all their all their profits on a
regular basis
never mind
I was trying to find a way that you
could have reserved funds well I guess
you could have set up a reserve in your
current structure yeah and and fund it
to follow up on it we do and on
technologies that have a lower uh kind
of First Step cost we do regularly
expand into areas that our customers are
following the blockchain space the
Staffing currently because of the
lucrative nature of cryptocurrency is uh
very expensive it's really the short
story here so it's it's a big leap from
what we would typically invest in to
attract the right people
Mr chairman
the FTX Scandal seemed to do a big
setback for all this cryptocurrency as
well as blockchain and so what were the
effects of that in your operation
ah so we were not impacted by that at
all um and I think uh that's a great
example but the state you guys are
already doing so things like House Bill
645 are going to provide a way to have a
skeleton where those companies actually
have to do reporting they have to follow
some of the rules that every other
business has to follow which provides
that security and this is one piece of
that puzzle that will help support that
ecosystem here in the state
follow-up as a replacement currency it
seems a little too volatile which is why
even though we've seen a lot of
inflation in the US dollar it's
it's more controlled than almost all the
other currencies in the world and and I
see this one being even more volatile
than the US dollar
would you agree uh currently I think
there's an incredible amount of
authority in in cryptocurrencies but
again I think crypto well it is today
the big piece of blockchain in the long
term there are other business cases
outside of that that will it has an
immense utility form
okay no more questions thanks for making
the trip
but I'm gonna ask Kathy I might ask you
to do me a favor of course
we have a bill that came in
it's 529 that has to do with uh a
formula for Distributing
cash based on student population
in house bill 529. in case you want to
see the verbiage
oh there is a house bill 529 oh
okay
yes yes
okay and I'm gonna I was gonna do this
privately but I think I'd rather do it
publicly
uh I like that formula not just because
it it
does it does
something well
it takes available funds and distributes
it based on valuation per student of the
town
exactly yes
okay I've I've just um representative
I'm happy to help in any way I can but
this is far outside I have I have made
my request yet
I'm just giving you a background okay
got it
and and as part of the background I I'm
from Hampton and we wouldn't qualify for
about anything that I'm going to talk
about so I'm shooting my feet off for my
own constituents but I think better
distribution of available funds is
appropriate
the current bill has basically three
levels of valuation per student
criteria one is less than six hundred
thousand dollars
two is six hundred thousand to one point
six million
and three is over 1.6 million
is
I would I would ask you to put your
thinking cap on back your treasury days
here
and help me develop a formula using this
concept
that we could use to distribute building
Aid we could use to distribute all what
we're doing here for uh uh free and
reduced meals I mean that same formula
could be used many places that then
takes the poor less valued communities
it gives them a greater piece
and when I I don't have an answer right
now but that the greater piece is is
that let's say one gets I'm making this
up
one gets three times what three gets
over 1.6 million you get one third of
what somebody in category one gets
that's the concept
and what I want what I'm trying to put
together is a formula
and I I don't know what it looks like
but it's just it's got these three
levels
and it's for distribution
analog if you will
that's your homework assignment if you
don't mind helping me out a little bit
Mr G we actually have a formula
that we use
um David luno has developed it in
conjunction with Rick Ladd um and Sally
fellows who was here
um
reporting actually what you are asking
Kathy to do Sally has done
um she used to work the New Hampshire
Department of Education she might be a
good person to ask to to translate it to
the other areas that you're looking at
Sally has quite she's a marble with
formulas and she's very familiar with
this okay well
representative fellows it's funny I just
ran into her and she's looking for work
right now
elevator and
um
I used to work with Sally fellows when
she worked for the Department of Ed and
I was with with the state and she knows
all of this
at a much deeper level than I do okay
eye level so a high level and and deep
so I I think she would be
an excellent resource I agree I'll
connect I'll connect you all right okay
all right I think the the
thing I mean it could be applied to a
number of top programs interesting
excuse me that um for for state aid for
whatever local school districts I I I
think the key to this when she was
presenting it was based on valuation per
student all of a sudden hey we've got a
denominator
we finally got a denominator instead of
planning our feed in midair
so I liked I really I was really struck
by what common sense that is
she actually was just in here asking me
if I have anything for her to do because
she wanted if I wanted her to put a
formula
let's get in touch with her
Kathy thank you anyway
congratulations to work
today being wombs day I want to
congratulate you I think you're the
first female athletic director at Uni
the University of New Hampshire I'm not
the first but I'm the first that's the
the whole department right not just
congratulations it's it's nice to have a
woman in that position and
congratulations to you all I just am so
impressed and my little granddaughter
little she's a freshman at UNH and I
have never seen such a happy girl she
loves every single day of her experience
at unh so thank you
let me asked one other question just
came to mind
this the 1.5 million is that what the
Yeah but yeah that's to hire people
yeah it's a three year over three years
so it's time
to say because what happens in year two
if you don't yeah
your Revenue up we'll get it up over the
three years that's that's why it's over
all right all right thank you the
thinking was that
developers thinking recommended by the
crypto
back here and asking for more money you
know and after three years we're either
self-supporting or we're not yep well it
appears here uh it it it's actually
appearing here in 23 fiscal year correct
right so it would roll I think the
intention will roll over the next three
okay
all right thank you very much and thank
you for being here
thank you thanks for the opportunity
appreciate it
I'm glad I asked
nope
okay Mickey you're you're the man
can I add the thanks to Mickey that he's
so good at filling our dance card and
when our dance card isn't full he's
really good he's a very good dance
partner
so what part of security are you change
your partner he's part of the family
okay sure
no he's uh he's a nephew um
oh really oh I'll be done
good guys I'm supposed to harassment
up
a little nepotism there I guess it
worked for me I don't think
carrying his own weight
so
as far as where we finish with UNH there
the school building Aid idea so that's
something I can help as well kind of
work through
um trying to come up with if you want to
Target some Aid based on some factors so
this one I just printed off here
the school building Aid formula now has
Grant determinations based on median
family income and equalized valuation in
that town that District so I just
presented this as there's already a
mechanism even relative to school
building Aid that targets
to uh to districts based on free and
reduced or if not free reduced on uh
income and valuation so that exists as
an idea the 529 House Bill 529 structure
is an idea there's a bunch of different
ways you could Target building a money
and uh
my thought process is to figure out a
formula
that could apply to all
distributions and building Aid and
free and reducing whatever
that it becomes its own paragraph
and over here it says go use that
paragraph
instead of rewriting it all the time are
you talking just School building or all
Aid programs I'm thinking of just eight
programs
categorically
[Music]
so adequacy to like special education
tuition transport like everything or at
adequacy in the sense of the increase
yeah base adequacy stays the same as it
has been to everybody the difference the
Delta that remains if we if we leave it
the full amount the Delta becomes new
formula okay
so even adequacy has has built into it
a benefit for Less wealthy communities
I
wasn't
just
were the
SE by
no
forget you know what I mean because we
had talked about we have the Medicaid
information by town
on percentages of kids that are on fnr
um and we had talked about maybe using
that number instead of the fnr number
we're currently using that we know is
inadequate
okay
yeah I think it's equalized valuation
versus
Medicaid Medicaid instead of Medicaid
you just have the uh
equalized values which which is going to
give you a percentage
and just as a quick note to build on
repeats comments I do I do agree with
the fact that the fnr numbers right now
are not accurate and don't represent the
you know poverty levels in the towns and
whether we you know start using Medicaid
or do something else based on valuations
or anything in between I think we need
to find the best way to fix that formula
and frankly I don't you know I think
we're okay changing the formula if we
that the governor proposed to something
that we feel is more appropriate if we
can you know reach a good agreement I
think we're all doing something
the question is could we resolve it by
coming up a formula and then use it
consistently and not have
the data point of percentage that call
could qualify for f and r
is just a data point it would have no
relevance to the formula itself it would
say in this town this is the percentage
but as far as the distribution of funds
I got to think about this I it just this
struck me in the middle of night last
night that's why I'm like a broken
record on this yeah I can't
I think the fnr is more subject to fraud
than a
equalized valuations
and I mean that we we heard years ago
about some superintendent going out and
recruiting
people to get more F and our money
and I'm thinking you know
that doesn't make sense
if people need it and they want it they
can come in and apply for it and I don't
know how
how thorough the analysis is to say
prove that
that was your income
are you leaving out something
I think I think the Medicaid that you're
talking about would do that
well either one would do it really I
mean you're just looking for a
percentage it gives you it gives you a
percentage of well you're you're
creating categories with an equalized
valuation that's one thing Medicaid
would also do it
because you're you know how many people
are on Medicaid which is the poverty
level basically yeah you know you can
translate that so I mean it's
you could do it either way but the
school building Aid could use the same
form absolutely
right well but that's it to be the same
thing really you're just doing it a
different way
this also uses
right well that's another issue which
you're using f
can I ask a clarifying question were you
considering using the equalized property
values as the the measure for more than
one of these Concepts yes okay so I
guess the question that I would have
then I can see where it might work for
some but I'm not sure that that would
work for in every instance that that
would grab the people I don't know every
instance yeah I just want to put it on
the table here's an idea can we make it
more fair if that's the right word
that's all yeah
go ahead
right well yeah no no probably lost my
train of thought but uh no this is per
valuation per student or as relation in
relation to students right which is
which is what you got to go by it may
not total evaluation I mean you know
because obviously Hampton is would be a
lot more a greater number per it was a
million and a half two and a half
million per per person our valuation is
uh 3.6 billion okay 15 000 people but
but we got 1800 students I mean I I
haven't played with it yet but but that
number is in relation to the number of
students in other words evaluation of
the number of students so you get a like
that's where this like Farmington would
be around six hundred thousand dollars
per student let's say okay so I mean and
and yours would be you know whatever two
and a half million per student which you
don't really qualify now so I'm sorry
about that I don't qualify now anyway
there you go I'm not doing anything Dan
just a quick Point since we were talking
about the Medicaid numbers earlier I
wanted to remind you that while the fnr
numbers are off because of the covid era
policies and our Medicaid numbers will
be off right now because we haven't been
allowed to knock anybody of the roles
that would have been knocked off so we
also have a temporary Distortion there
so in a sense looking at something like
529 that kind of takes all those
variables out and you know it's just
harder to tweak with by anybody who
would want to put their thumb on the
formula and affect it that seems to be a
very hard one to do it with because it's
just you know valuations a number of
kids and it's a very straightforward
thing so I I really you know I'm
comfortable with 529 as a formula for
deciding how to allocate
Aid to you know or contributions to
municipalities based on their
educational needs you know even if it's
on a broader set but whatever part of
the formula deals with a relative need
or inability to provide I think that
would be a good measure to use in
different categories
yeah very I just want to clarify the
process for frame reduced lunch
um lunch forms are provided to All
Families in all districts
um who
to everybody and those who are eligible
can fill them out and they go back to
the usually the food nutrition program
in the school district and they are
validated they're they're and I think
Joe you can speak to this much better
than I can because you've actually done
some of this
um they are validated I just I just
wanted everybody to realize
um who might be listening today that um
people
in school districts do go above and
beyond to make sure but the problem is
the
often the forms are never returned they
get lost in kids book book bags they
and I think a joke and talk to it better
than I can yeah I think thank you uh if
I may uh like our our town right now or
our school district is uh we got 760 odd
students
we are short
144 forms from the norm of last
from the 2019 statistic because that's
what we're using for so that and that
and so that what's that translate to
about three hundred thousand dollars
well that's 75 cents on a tax rate right
there and that's we don't know why they
haven't turned them in I mean you know
you get used to not filling out the form
so so then people say well I don't have
to do that anymore so they you know they
don't do it or or for other reasons they
don't want to give their data but it is
they take about three percent at the end
you know uh well and they're randomly
picked to certify to ought to do an
audit a random audit and if they don't
turn their forms in those those kids
necessarily will come off the rolls
because you know if they don't provide
the data so
Chester right now we're seeing a really
serious drop in adequacy funding
um number one because we're using
different student counts because there's
been a reduction after Kobe never fully
came back and secondly
um
folks got used to not having to fill out
the forms so they're not filling out the
forms and additionally we have a huge
population of English as a second
language uh Learners and families and
the families we try to get social
workers out to them but they haven't
been completely successful and parents
for whatever reason in the world so our
numbers are way off in comparison to
what the Medicaid count might be and
then what our actual fnr numbers are and
I have a sense that this is happening in
a lot of places like Manchester
um you know Nashua might be similar you
you Farmington obviously some is worth
Claremont because school districts just
get used to not doing them and so now
getting parents to do them again is just
that extra hurdle that that we're not
getting by well right now and
unfortunately
the formula is really so dependent that
epinr carries some weight so our school
district says suffering
with the funding because the numbers
aren't as high
well anyway let's think about it I I
think it's a an opportunity to
partially fix that and I think that's
what 529 addresses yeah
all right Mickey Mouse now it's your
turn
so so just to kind of piggyback on that
conversation we've got a limited amount
of time and this is massively complex
especially if we're going to cross over
a building Aid formula with adequacy and
you know so whatever Direction This
committee wants to go in with all that
we it'd be nice to do it on the front
end so we can make sure that I can
calculate accurate estimates for all
that the spreadsheets and everything
um you know we talked about adjusting
adjustment to frame reduce we talked
about uh the governor's proposal which
gets rid of stabilization and creates a
new hold harmless we've talked about 529
which has two brand new components to
the Ed funding formula as well as 540
which is the special education
enhancements representative lad's bill
so there's a lot of moving pieces with
that so
um I'm not sure if today's going to be
the day we're going to dive into it but
I'll try to come up with something that
can be a useful tool for
committee moving forward but I'd say we
probably should start zeroing in on what
direction you want to go event funding
soon
thank you Mr chair in order for us to
make a decision I think it would be very
useful if we would take a peek at how
would the distributions
um to the town's work if instead of the
fnr if in the fnr portion of the
governor proposed budget we would use
the formula proposed by 529 instead I
think it would be necessary to look at
how that will affect Aid you know that
particular portion of way to the various
towns to see whether we do get the
overall positive results we all expect
because I would expect that to be better
and more fair but until we run the
numbers we wouldn't know and the quicker
we do that you know I I would feel that
it's a good use of time if we could just
run that you know substitute in the fnr
portion of the governor budget the
formula proposed by 529 run the same
amount of dollars that the governor
suggests for now so we can have on Apple
so Apple's comparison so we'd have to
change the rate per student but you know
and you know see how how that moves the
same put the money around and whether
it's more appropriate
can I just add with regard to building
it I think in the future that's that's a
wonderful proposal to try and look at
that
but I just I just want to go back to my
statement that we're just coming off a
moratorium and there are a lot of school
districts that have already gone through
the process so I'd like to for this year
just honor as much as we can and and
hopefully get a few more projects in
that could be funded
um and not move to a totally different
system because I don't think anybody's
ready for it we really haven't had
public hearings on any of that so just
to keep the status quo for school
districts for this
session and then maybe next session
start working on that because I think
it's a heavy lift moving to something
like that
oh no doubt about it
yeah
oh thank you uh
as far as the 529 formula
Farmington would get about a million
dollars more so that's that's and and if
you look at that chart
uh that was provided that's that's quite
I mean that's quite significant that's
and that's that's the governor's
proposal plus uh
uh stop loss
and and the 529 Edition uh usually
equalized valuation
information
right right
we are actually last night we did the
city budget and we did the School
District budget and there are
significant holes in our education
budget because of the loss of adequacy
dollars it's significant and this would
really help us
and just uh make sure everyone
understands how the whole harmless works
and what putting 529 on top of that
would mean in the case of Farmington
the governor's proposal has 2.3 million
dollars of a hold harmless so a
Farmington got an extra 1.2 million from
the 529 that just means their hold
harmless would go down by that amount so
there would be no net increase
yep it comes out to what 5.8 million yep
but it would essentially be a shift so
you'd get the 529 money but your hold
harmless would go down
yeah but that's that's not what it says
to that call them
it's holds harmless plus bar 29.
which what says if you go across that
column the representative fellow sheet I
can't speak to that sheet I didn't I
didn't run that one I don't know that's
that's the way that 529 if you wanted to
craft I mean then
we I think we need to have a deeper dive
into education funding I think because I
don't think we're ready to do this today
right I'm not ready to do this today I'm
sorry I didn't have anything with me for
that but it mean I can't pull something
out of my ear to solve it right now
yes could you explain a little more the
hold harmless what is being held
harmless
in the governor's proposal there's three
big changes so there's
the uh changes to base adequacy and the
free and reduced lunch portion of
differentiated those eight amounts go up
then also stabilization Grant goes away
to hold harmless is set up so when you
make all those changes
and you compare what that formula
computes for each Town to what it would
have received under current law with the
fiscal 24 preliminary estimates that
went out the hold harmless would
represent any shortfall between the
governor's proposal and what they would
have got under current law so in the
case of Farmington they were 2.3 million
dollars less under the governor's
proposal than current law so there was a
2.3 million dollar hold harmless
but if we but if we change the formula
to give Farmington an extra million they
would only need a 1.3 million dollar
hold harmless but still would get the
same amount as their fiscal 24 current
law preliminary estimate so hold
harmless is what you called
stabilization
it's a it's exactly the same yeah it's
essentially the same yeah
so first I do agree with earlier remarks
that the more we can do to chip away at
the harmless because you know a whole
harmless at the end of the day is a way
of saying the formula doesn't work we
are going to maintain it for now but we
agree that money shouldn't really be
there so if if if just changing the
formula may not get new dollars but it
gives a certain Community money you know
in the proper pocket instead of through
the whole harmless which will go away
that in itself is a good thing because
it makes the formula better and it
clearly shows that you know we are
really addressing this more nicely and
again hold harmless will get go away but
I do want to make
clear that what I requested earlier as a
research and I want to make sure that
we're all on the same pages I did not
look at the new money proposed in 529
for now I just asked for an analysis of
what would happen if we take the formula
from 529 and apply to the current
governor budget so we compare the same
number of dollars with the same number
of dollars so we just look at the
formula impact any funding changes we
can discuss separately but the initial
step for me is just same dollars
allocated to two different formulas so
we can see how it moves around I think
529 actually has dollars in it I agree
it does but the the the project that I
was asking Mickey for was that same
dollar is just the formula change and we
can talk about the money separate so can
I ask can I ask you a question
um my city Manchester so Manchester
got the additional
like this question is does the the I
believe the governor's
budget does not include the
Erin Hennessey funding that came out
remember me like my city was given
additional dollars for
um poverty and and
um property values
um I believe the governor's
formula excludes that yeah I should have
mentioned the relief relief Aid yes and
the third grade reading component that's
a small amount those are not in the
governor's proposal either yes so so for
Manchester representative
um
in real really what is driving the whole
harmless is the stabilization Grant
elimination so Manchester for instance
has a stabilization Grant of
so
12.5 just about 12.5 million dollars
so in the new formula the governor's
proposal Manchester has a hold harmless
of 3.6 million so essentially the
changes in the formula
could increase Manchester about 9
million but when you took the
stabilization away you still needed a
new stabilization to keep you at the
same funding level
same idea for Farmington
in many other towns so when you're when
you compare the new the increase in Aid
proposed by the governor to the loss of
stabilization for many towns that
it wasn't enough which is what resulted
necessitated the hold harmless so no
town would have less money you'd have
the same
yeah according to this 529 chart here
Manchester would uh increase by about 12
million dollars from
uh 62 million to around 75 million so
that's and the and and it's Governors
have to hold harmless
and current RSA plus 529 which is
stabilization I I as I would understand
it
I'll be honest I did not look at
representative fellows data so I can't
speak to that but that that's what
that's exactly what it says here so I
mean yeah I don't I don't know I don't
know how I I don't know how she got her
numbers I'll be honest I trust her
implicitly she did this for a living and
she's very good at it I says I don't I
think she also may have done that prior
to House Bill 2 coming out so I don't
know if she made an assumption that she
did you know so so I don't I just can't
speak to that I've just been going off
of my my calculations I did them
independently to doe we came up to the
same place so that's kind of what I'm
working off of right now okay
do we do we have that yeah Department
had provided that okay when they had
come in the 28th I think the afternoon
or the 28th so we have that
okay
looking at what Sally fellows passed out
and I can share with you if you don't
have it
it shows State total
current RSA 598 million
Governors beforehold harmless is 566
million so even though he says he's
giving more per pupil it appears that
it's less when she throws out all these
other things and then the governor's
after hold harmless is 653.
and then current RSA plus HB 529 it goes
up again another 40 million to 694 so
you know the things at the top I'm
looking at I I would say the biggest
difference between the governors and 529
is the stabilization Grant 529 does not
remove the stabilization Grant so that
is going to be above and beyond versus
netting against the loss of a
stabilization Grant and I think that's
that's the the big difference between
what is in the governor's proposal in
is gone it it would net it would if you
increase the made you're just going to
eat into how much hold harmless you have
to give or new stabilization we'll call
it so there's a netting going on so
that's why I think when Mark had given
numbers yesterday
he had said it's a little bit less than
what representative fellow said and
that's because yeah there's more money
going to be in this new Aid component
529 which means we just have to give
less hold harmless but that Town's still
going to get the same amount of money as
just 529 plus hold harmless it's just
gonna be less hold harmless so there's
no State net increase some towns may you
may have some town that that 529 was
just enough to exceed their whole
harmless so they're going to get more
but in those two examples I just gave
Farmington and Manchester they're not I
can guarantee Berlin is not another one
there there is another one that just
because they have a huge stabilization
adding these new components in 529 would
not exceed or reach how much their
stabilization Grant is
yeah it wouldn't reach into that right
now but given that the plan is to hold
that stabilization Grant you know until
everybody catch up that town would catch
up faster in the future and would get
additional funds earlier if we make
those changes versus the current Formula
where they would be you know have to
make up more stabilization Aid so I
agree that if we just look at this
biennium they may not be impacted but it
will accelerate their ability to
increase funding in the future presuming
everything stays unchanged
and I think we're not going to solve
this this morning and I think would be I
think Mickey has a whole long list of
things we really got to get to I think
this is good to discuss it I just didn't
come prepared with it today that's why I
feel a little uh you know not helpful so
uh no representative is correct that uh
the governor is proposing a 10-year plan
with the phasing out of the hold
harmless with an enhancement to the
extraordinary needs Grant which is based
on equalized valuation per free and
reduced lunch pupil so over time there
should be a shift
I am only running this biennial budget
at this point so we we have not I don't
plan to do a 10-year analysis on this
with the time that we have so this
document actually was representing
fellows yes
okay
wow and yeah and while I completely
agree that we should focus on this
biennium
when we do talk about formulas that will
be presumably presumably part of the
statute for an extended period of time
even if we don't have hard numbers it is
useful to understand at least at a
qualitative level what the impact will
be without the need to have dollars and
cents you know at a very accurate level
but and I think doe did provide a a line
graph that they showed at the bottom
which is total and you can see that
shift over time
um but that's that's not something I
don't think anyone's gonna have a town
by town for to see what happens in 2028
for instance was not asking for that at
all okay
okay we're on your agenda now
uh so I I did appreciate that
conversation because that's been on my
in my opinion that's one of the biggest
things on division two's plate is Ed
funny it always is so just having the
dialogue about I think is good and
productive and you know continue to work
through that one uh so it's only a
billion dollars only a billion dollars
so I do have an updated packet it's not
that different than the last time we
sent this out it has the binder clip on
it uh the first the first document is
exactly the same this is our house bill
2 houseboat one back of the budget
sections and House Bill 2 uh assigned
sections I don't know Mr chair if you
wanted to go through and
just check off what what might be ones
that there's a general consensus for and
just uh as well we're gonna have to do
it at some point for instance in my
opinion nothing's going to get easier
than the house bill one back of the
budget section so these are sections of
law that essentially make the budget
work one of them is the lottery
commission's authority to purchase their
their tickets and the other is just the
I call it cleanup agencies will have
abolished vacant positions that are put
forward we didn't hear from any of the
agencies to change what is in house bill
one that came over from the governor so
to me sections four and five of house
bill one you could probably accept as
they came to you
to move okay
I didn't know we were going to do any
voting today oh it's fine I don't yeah I
don't I don't think any voting we would
do today would be uh oh you mean from
Clark's point of view I'm sorry yeah oh
it's
and this is just more of our tentative
Choy hands type thing probably works for
me to
um do what does Janet need a record of
this well I
think usually I can put it in the
narrative yeah
well you could just you probably could
just use the sheet
yeah okay here but you know five zero
yeah as a queen up got it because that's
what we're doing cleaning up the dock
right yeah so we have a motion to for
items for the Lottery Commission and for
yeah section four and five page seven
section four and five yep all those in
favor
above
just those two items
okay everybody okay
yeah got it
all right and just so everyone knows how
when when I prepare this document again
for Friday yeah I'll I'll have in that
column accept or something along those
lines so it's clear you're making no
changes to the bill as it came to you
and then you'll know that oh that's off
our plate
um I don't know how if we wanted to talk
any funding at this point so a lot of
the sections in House Bill 2 are
Appropriations uh We've do one
concurrent enrollment the program
changes relative to that we had house
bill
I don't know I mean the the this
is what the governor proposed 2 million
we also had another bill that had 3.25
million dollars for
doing concur enrollment that was also
the Community College systems request
so this is still a two and a half
million dollar
item so I'm not sure if we're in a
position to do that today
I don't think so probably not is my
guess yeah you also have a section
uh section two or excuse me six and
seven relative to the community college
system they had come forward with
language the governor supported it to
essentially have employees hired after
January 1st 2024 not be part of the
retirement system we haven't heard from
the community college system
specifically on that because they came
in before hb2 was introduced they did
suggest that was in there so I don't
know if
I don't know if we wanted to have the
community college system in for a
follow-up on some of their items it's up
to you Mr chair I don't
if you call them and ask them a question
that's sufficient for me I'm dragging
them back in here okay it's like
oh
you gotta turn your mic on Mike Mike
okay
I am not in favor of it because it
reduces the um number of Union employees
at the community college so for me I
just am not comfortable acting on that
just now
so we can skip
that the U.S or the UNH
um Appropriations we heard we just heard
from them on those I don't know it's a
lot of money it's nine and a half
million over the biennium it's all
charged a fiscal 23 Surplus
I don't know where everyone is with that
whether you support that those funding
those Appropriations at this time or you
still want to keep it depressed
these are General funds
so but again what's anybody's sense of
that of these two items we just heard
from UNH I'm fine with the two items um
I guess I'm sorry there are two people
who aren't participating in this but I'm
you know I suspect they would be fine
with it too although I shouldn't speak
for them but I'm fine with these two we
have underfunded the university system
for so long
um and this is an opportunity I feel
like that we can do something
both the Whittemore and the um uh
whatever they call it blockchain they're
both Revenue generating items that will
allow them to not come back to us so
often they're going to be making more
money from these they're kind of like
Enterprise so I I support them and I
hope that when we get to the line the
operating line we can bring the
university system back to the 100
million dollars that we had back in
2011. yeah I want to add that this we
consider this not as a replacement for
increasing the basic line for the
University because I would still support
that and personally because it's a lot
of money and we still don't have a clear
handle on the revenues and whatever all
the other budget pieces go and also we
need to understand what our overall
goals are you know as a finance
committee and then kind of see what each
subcommittee each you know division
needs to do I would want to wait on
voting for a large ticket items
regardless of the topic just until we
understand the priorities and uh you
know what what whatever our strategy is
our budget this is unaffected this is
coming out of 23. Surplus
that's what I'm looking at it right but
if it's hb2 for this year you can you
know using funds that you know go in the
2023 or could affect what we're doing 24
and 25 we could you know decide I'm not
talking about this particular item but
in general right
there is nothing to stop up stop us from
saying something that the governor wants
in 24 but it has non-lapsing in 23 if we
have the funds there but we don't have
the funds in 24 and 25. so I just want
to wait a little bit until we have a
better handle of priorities before we
talk about any big ticket items
regardless of the topic well one thing
though I think it's
when you have a budget there are a lot
of things you want to buy and you figure
out what it is you want to buy
and then you hit find out how much money
you have and then you go back and you
say well I only have this much money I
can only buy this many things and that's
by saying that we're all in agreement
about certain things we can say okay we
all like this if we have enough money we
can buy it so I think it's just if we
can like kind of get a consensus and
then when you find out how much we can
spend then we can say well we as much as
we like it we can't do it
does that make sense yeah and I would
add that we always you know this is a
first pass we go back once we have the
money and we'll say okay you know we'd
like to this but we need to we're going
to need to cut a million here and there
and so we go back and revise the budget
but this is the first pass to say yeah
if we have the money this is something
we definitely want to do uh we'll come
back we're going to come back over this
at least two three four times
I'm if we're going to go back and forth
I would suggest we try to prioritize and
say is this priority one two or three
maybe three would be sufficient and as
we go through each of these decide what
the priority is and agree to that and
then move on to the next one okay I
think it probably yeah I think it sounds
like we probably should hold off on that
for now on the spending and it
and just a reminder all of these are
already in the governor's budget the
next the next document we'll get to will
be the add-ons but this is already
already included everything else in
House Bill 2 we're going to be hearing
from the Department of Safety and Dot
today which will will hopefully get us
in a good place to to feel good or or
not about these items and then I'm going
to schedule the Department of Education
to come join us next week uh I'm not
sure the day yet it's going to depend on
I think we've got some full committee
things that we're going to get scheduled
uh and and
the other the last thing relative to
uh our assignment in House Bill 2 that
is not an agency specific if you jump on
the second page all the way to sections
210 and 211 and this is what we talked
about the the shift in the uh
distribution of business taxes between
the general and education trust fund
so depending on where the the education
trust fund is and uh what this
committee's policy is that's got to be
determined at some point but I don't
think we're ready to do that today
either
so some of these appear to be non-cash
items yes you want to want to just deal
with the non-cash owners we can I don't
know if you want to hear from the
departments on them first like many of
many of dots I don't think are directly
related to the budget but they're going
to come in with explanation as to why
they need those and that's today so even
if we don't Circle back this afternoon
because I think we've got a stop at time
today uh we can certainly do these uh
Friday we'll be informed then we can
roll through on Friday
oh
okay and even on a non-cash item in
today's budget technically if we decide
that's not a priority even though they
are not requesting money we could be
able to you know remove some funds that
would have otherwise been used for this
if needed so even non-cash items unless
they are very minimal you know I would
wait a little just to see what
flexibility you're coming in right
they're going to speak to these items
exactly so I'd rather have that
information yeah
so on the next page the busy uh
spreadsheet looking page I you will see
some shading uh we we've made a couple
changes here mostly technical in nature
we did add the fish and game position
you see that on line 32.
on here everything does touch Highway
and general funds with the exception of
we did get a late uh dot correction
request on line 40. so this actually has
a net zero it was similar to something
we had done for uh
the Lottery Commission I think it was
where there's just a source of funding
issue in the budget so
there used to be a revolving fund set up
for this accounting unit now it's not a
revolving fund that fund was repealed
but it is dedicated restricted Revenue
so it's really just a revenue class code
it's a Beyond technical in nature it's
very technical so if the committee is
okay with line 40 I can make that change
and it sure won't even really notice it
but it's something I'd still want
to know you I did it yeah
you gotta go for it all right excellent
everything else on here is is general or
uh
Highway except for if you look at lines
19 and 20 for the Department of Safety
this this comes out of what we refer to
as the fire fund and when the department
of safety comes in today they'll be
talking about their house bill two
sections which include changing the uh
how the fees on the motor vehicle
certified record copies is handled which
indirectly relates to this so I think we
got to wait and see what we decide to do
with House Bill 2 before you'll know the
affordability of those uh those sections
19 and 20.
if you uh flip over to the next page
I updated this based on yesterday's
action so we moved virtually all of our
bills up to retain now for Budget
consideration we still have the two EFA
bills pending we got scheduled for a
work session again on Friday at 10 to
vote on those uh I I'm I don't know if
we wanted to go through these bills that
have retained to at least see if there's
consensus for me to go forward and start
drafting amendments or if you want to
wait for another time for that because
many of them do have money associated
with them
well we have a better idea of what
the budget is
and we've got Ways and Means and we've
got the governor so now at least we have
numbers
I don't I
so if these are retained what what
action are you looking forward from us
today
so if if you want to support them and
budget them put them in the budget so
some of them we retained and I'll pick
on uh
uh let me see I'll pick on
House Bill 560. the contact note of
person notification program which was a
bill we retained the bill included uh
five fifty thousand dollar appropriation
for the Department of Safety to update
their system for this database for the
contact uh folks is that something that
committees and I want to include right
now
page two of the the busy spreadsheet oh
I'll just say that that bill was a
consent calendar bill in the house
so the way we left that work session is
we retained it for Budget consideration
so the question is do you want it in
your budget do you want me to go forward
draft an amendment you know and and we
don't have to do this today but as I've
I've collected all these bills here for
Budget consideration at some point I
just don't want them to fall through the
cracks if if the committee does want to
fund these and put them in House Bill
too we do need to drive them Governor
has a building a budget line
for building a yes yep so we could adopt
the governor's
budget yeah so if you wanted to support
the governor's position on school
building Aid these three bills we just
wouldn't do those cool building a bills
would just may still be retained and uh
and you'd move forward with what's in
house bill one and two as is
we've got we've got to make Cuts
somewhere and I don't there's a lot of
money going into building Aid which we
cannot afford because what I saw and I'm
sure Mickey will agree
what ways and means gives us is 80
million dollars less than what the
governor's budget so when we look at
some of these bills we've got to be
making Cuts rather than additions
because we don't have the money
what
my attention quickly focused on 75
million that became available June 30th
2025.
to me that makes no sense at all
I mean I'll start there
and say forget that so now we're down to
13 million
that that's the government
building a building a but a traditional
yes so that's section
s 165 and one
through 167 in house bill 2. so if
that's if if the committee you know has
a consensus of not supporting that 75
million dollar dedicated for you know we
would take those sections out and I'm
just going to jump to the two pages
ahead and the packet I just gave you the
education trust fund
picture
so if you look at line 37 of this that
75 it looks the educational custom
snapshot
so 75 million dollars that row would
essentially become zero right which
would have a corresponding increase to
your ending balance of the education
trust fund
60 plus 75 yeah
yeah so it's it's sections 165 through
167 and House Bill 2 are relative to
establishing the school building a fun
the CTE
's going to talk to the chair of
so capital I would say that should go to
Capital
included
there's yeah there's there's no CT
renovation or Construction in the
capital budget there's not and I believe
the department has
brought up so there's one for the Sugar
River Valley uh in in House Bill 2 paid
for with education trust funds I believe
there is a second project but I don't
know the status I think it's gonna Squam
uh but I don't know if that's locally
approved I don't have all the details on
that but I think that was brought up at
Public Works and highways the second
project
I don't believe I don't know I don't
believe so
five right yeah the governor just
changed the policy on this it proposed
the policy change to have this paid
forward yeah opposed to that policy
change and I think this is way better
handled under cap this is where it
belongs and I think I I feel there's
sort of an end run that's being
attempted here uh we don't have the
processes to go through this it needs to
go public work so I'm very happy to move
that off our plate and onto theirs
it seems like this is an exception to
the tradition
if if the if the desire is to fund this
renovation
we would need definitely definitely need
to coordinate with public works and
highways so if you do if you deleted
that from host Bill 2 we can't tell them
to put in house bill 25. so as long as
it's clear between the two committees
what's going on we can do we can do
anything we can
so if if this is all set can I go back
and ask about the you know 75 million uh
you know uh for the building Aid at the
end of the year the page 59 section 165
to 167 because I thought when we were
talking about it I think everybody was
saying that they would be comfortable
striking that out for now
and I would suggest that if everybody is
on board we may as well take care of it
and uh you know because we know we'll
have to find more savings anyway and
we'll come back to building Aid because
we have a big discussion about it but I
I don't think anybody here feels that
that's really the right way I think we
agreed to strike that one so then 15
page 59 sections 165 167 for the 75
million transfer
that is gone for now and I will I will
point out if you go if everyone has
their house bill too and you go to uh
page 60
so section 165 that starts on the
previous page establishes the dedicated
account for school building in the 75
million
166 makes a couple other changes
including a relative to a facility
assessment so I just want to make sure
that you want to not do any of this
before we just go ahead and wipe out
like if you wanted to because there's
other things happening in here besides
just a straight 75 million dollar I have
no problem with administrative shifts or
whatever the other things are it's just
that money come popping up the last day
of the biennium
facility assessment is that what we
asked for actually what uh
representative Ladd was looking for for
the the assessment on all the buildings
across the state is that what that is
I I think more or less I don't think
it's exactly married to the bill from
from last time uh if you jump to
um line 28 you'll really see the you
know to comply with the requirements the
Department of Education shall contract
with a vendor to conduct a facility
assessment of public schools and Charter
Public Schools to create a ranked list
of schools so there's there's work here
and presumably some of that 75 million
would have gone to doe to to do that
requirement
um and we we can ask the department
about that when we get them in here I
think at the very least it sounds the
committee has the cons is
has consensus to not do the special
State Building Aid account with the 75
million as far as this facility
assessment perhaps we can talk through
that with the Department maybe that
might remain but the 75 million portion
comes out I agree with you completely
yeah the other thing
um and I guess we'll talk about this as
well at the top of the page there's the
The Proposal was a 75 million coming out
of the education trust fund and going
into the
um building fund and I would like to
make sure that there's no sense of
the education trust fund money being
used
in the building fund or you know that
those are two different pots and I
didn't necessarily want to but does do
we take money out of the education trust
fund for building up for the past three
bienniums we've done that we have
um put building Aid into the trust and
we've used the trust as a source of
building Aid yes which goes into the
building yes okay yes just to clarify
there is no school building Aid fund
this was being proposed in this so if
you don't do this there's no building
Aid fund there's just a line in the
budget from the education trust Center
but there's no fund for school building
Aid yep
the education trust fund has grown
Beyond its Inception it was just for
adequacy and as it grew because the
business profits and so on were growing
we had all this extra money we would
really be in a world of hurt if we came
out with we put 60 million surplus into
an education trust fund
and was short 60 million somewhere else
in general fund we've got to change the
formula my suggestion had been and I
think
LBA might be working on it is to take
out the peace that comes from the
business profits and business Enterprise
tax the governor reduces it in here it
goes from 50 to 35 percent I think if we
took it out altogether there would still
be enough money in the education trust
fund for adequacy and we would go back
to all these other things that we always
took out a general fund anyway
but this 75 million to me it appears to
be well this is money that would go in
the education trust fund we'll just
throw it into building Aid
but you know I don't I don't think
that's the best arrangement I think we
should need to reduce what goes into
education trust fund which isn't needed
for education
adequacy because that's the design of
the thing that's what got us through the
court system
Court didn't argue that we had to put it
in building Aid and special ed and
tuition and transportation they didn't
care about any of that they just wanted
to make sure adequacy was covered that
was the whole purpose of the education
trust fund and it's gone beyond its its
use so we've got to bring it back in I
feel so we have more flexibility in
general fund spending we definitely need
that
you what I feel that I don't agree with
you I see your point you're ready to
spend every last dollar on education but
when can't afford it thank you I am I
know you are
I think that's another discussion in
terms of looking at that but I see your
you know I totally see your point but I
am not sure this is the the way I would
approach doing it
Mike Mike
right uh I I have a question on that and
if there if the education trust fund is
short then it would come out of General
funds anyway so so that that kind of
frees up money
just
to be clear I I at the end of the day we
decide what gets spent on education by
the way I mean the overall you know
finance committee in the house and
everybody involved but regardless of
what the account the trust fund is an
accounting device nothing more it's one
pocket or the other and I I do happen to
agree with you know chairman Weiler's
point that by putting stuff that can go
in the general fund into a pocket where
we cannot touch it for what we may
decide our greater needs at the time
we're limiting the flexibility and
creating more HB to work every year and
it's just gonna end up overridden in
every way I mean it would make sense as
long as we fund it appropriately which
is our duty to do and you know we have
to it wouldn't hurt to look at changing
the revenue that goes into it to get
more flexibility than general fund but
it's way too early to decide right now
again I just want to look at way more
numbers but in principle I think the
idea has married I think we have way
more work to do and that isn't
in our purview right now so that would
be like taking on another argument as
far as I'm concerned Mickey can we
proceed
I'm not sure what point you're making
my point is I don't want that to happen
I do oh oh the reduction of so we we're
we're agreeing to disagree I don't
believe that we are right now at a point
where we're going to start talking about
changing taxes that go into the trust
I'd like to do our work
oh
part of hb2
it's on page 17. my my opinion only
don't pay 75 about
it's on page 75 section uh 210. yeah
210.
and 211.
um
sorry no I I just I have a new topic but
I didn't know if this topic was uh yeah
we're done I just had to clarify what I
just wanted to check if we made a
decision on hb560 that contact person
notification the 50 000 that was passed
on a Voice vote
I mean it's 50 000 it was passed on a
void Voice vote it came out of committee
190 is that something we need more time
to think about
it right okay
so we all concur
I think you know I just gotta find where
to record that hang on oh you can do it
on your hp2 sheet
so so where I would track that for us
next time is if we go to just back to
that first house bill 2 schedule
on page two down at the bottom there's a
House Bill two amendments new so I'll
list amendments that we draft that are
not changing existing sections right
down there so we'll track everything
house bill 560.
19 Owen committee you know
safety didn't ask for that this this is
the result of a bill that came to us and
looking forward right yeah we briefly
discussed it with with the commissioner
and director Lavoy on the first when
they were in uh we'll have them in again
today if anyone has any follow-ups but I
think they were good they don't think
they'll object to us having approved it
yes
stuff off the table so if there's no
other questions on the bills and I will
I will update it when I am working on an
estimate for the placement of the
episode of treatment payments from the
bill we heard yesterday uh Rebecca Ross
from HHS came and saw us after lunch as
far as how much would be associated with
that so I'm still working on that but
once I have a number there I'll update
this to let you know how much that bill
would cost as far as how much to carry
as a budget adjustment for that bill I
think what I heard in the lobby was 2
million something but again that's a
Lobby number not a did we make a
decision to um include that in the line
where court order placements will go so
that's that will become an additional
item under that
so we would have to we could so
certainly that that accounting unit is
called court ordered placement so
perhaps we rename it just so it's clear
or a line I could figure out
mechanically how to make that work in
the budget the decision for you would be
just uh do you want it to be the same
funding source which is
under current law General funds under
the governor's proposal education trust
funds so court ordered placements
changes where it comes from in this
budget before you so you just need to
make it clear whoop which uh fund you
want those to come from yeah I would I
would try to take it out of general fund
and be a little bit more careful of
everything in education trust fund is
basically going to adequacy
trust fund yeah what's that and not load
up the trust funds no not load up to
trust fund because as I said when we
created it in about 2 000 it was because
we were being sued that we weren't
adequately funding education so we said
all right here's here's the formula this
is what we need this is going to go into
this education trust fund we set all
those things up and we deliberately
wanted it to be less than what it would
take so it because it went over that
money couldn't be used anywhere else
right okay but if it was little under we
could put in general fund about shaking
the world too much but if it went over
that money was lost for everything else
now it's become just a funding source
yeah and so for Education yeah for
education
it was set up to defend Us in the
Claremont soup and if we keep that in
mind that was his origin that was why
it's there it's not there to build up
this huge thing that we can say we can
use it here we can use it there we can
put more building a no leave it for what
it was created for representative I
would like to remind you that we have
two current lawsuits in place right now
that will always go on lawyers
can I ask I hate to be the one to bring
this up in the past there's never been
will for retroactive building Aid and
bless representative Cahill for bringing
it back every year and working so hard
to do that but you know we've got the 33
million over the biennium here and is
there do you think there's flavor for
retroactive funding of building Aid this
this session if there isn't then
and frankly
I just want to say I I talked to Michael
I don't know how many times about this
he's very very fervent
um to get that money for his community
but it has never ever been the practice
Amy said she'd do it if she work if we
said that she had to but I just think
we've got all these projects they knew
when they built that building that
building Aid was in a moratorium and
they knew they didn't go through the
process I feel terrible about it he's
fighting hard for it and he should be
it's the it's Community but
it's retro it's not and never has been a
practice that we retroactive pay for
building Aid and well
is as somebody who's been the you know
chairman of the school board in Windham
when we passed our project which would
be one one of those that would benefit
you know I cannot justify asking the
rest of the state to pay for what the
town of Windham agreed to pay for
knowing full well they were not gonna
get any any amount of tax dollars
regardless of how much nicer it would
have been if we received some we knew at
the time we agreed to it as it is I
don't think it's morally you know okay
for me to you know as much as I want to
represent my community it's not you know
the kind of the presentation I can
provide and you know
so I think that it is perfectly
acceptable to remove the retroactive uh
portion of that deal I I wouldn't oppose
that at all
so does that change the it doesn't
really change anything we're just not
adopting anything or so I mean would it
would it benefit the committee if I just
removed that bill from this working
document moving forward okay
yeah okay
we have plenty of other retained bills
that we can use
yeah if we want to change anything with
the uh the building Aid we can amend one
of the other bills uh we actually would
probably just do it right in House Bill
too oh yeah fine either way so all these
are really just on here for just
remembering the proposal we're not going
to use those as a vehicle I don't
believe at this point we'll use House
Bill too yeah okay
keep reminding me of that my mind keeps
going a different direction there's
there's there's nothing wrong with doing
that it's just in my opinion keeping all
of your proposals and your budget
package to one and two keeps it clear
sometimes you need to pass a bill
separately with money for whatever
reasons but most of these I think if
you're going to do school building Aid
you would just take care of it now spell
two
so that would apply also to 529
yeah yeah 529 540 uh we would we would
handle that in the house bill too as far
as as part of the education funding
change proposals
um so if if there's no more questions on
the retain bills I will jump down real
quick those other items so these are not
necessarily agency requests these are
just things that have popped up so we
had heard from the Department of
Education about perhaps carrying a
number on this education trust fund
Surplus statement relative to the snap
eligible population that is not in their
data sets to calculate but will be in
the payments that they make for Ed
funding they don't have true data on
that yet because it's just just began
they had estimated if we had held 10
million dollars in fiscal 24 and 20
million dollars in fiscal 25 to just
cover whatever that cost could be that
would be a number that they'd feel
comfortable with they don't want to
have the education trust fund not
recognize that and then not have
appropriate uh funds in there to make
the payments but they do anticipate Ed
funding will be a little bit higher and
that's just the number they're
estimating
okay
once there is a maintenance of effort
thing as well in this feds fund most of
it this this was if you recall uh fiscal
had approved a plan change I believe and
I'm speaking out at darn here with HHS
related programs but that snap went from
185 to 200 uh and that was approved by
fiscal uh in the winter sometime and
what that will do starting payments
going out next year uh any child who was
in between 185 and 200 would hit the
free and reduced lunch counts therefore
adequacy would be more doe doesn't have
the data to do in the spreadsheets now
to recognize those students so they're
saying they think it might be 10 to 20
million dollars in the next two years so
let's plan on that carry a budget item
reflecting that just so we're covered
it would be prudent to do so because we
know the expenditure will be there and
you know
we should set aside the best estimate we
have for those funds that comes out of
the
distribution yes that would essentially
be when when the actual spending happens
it'll be out of adequacy right but we
wouldn't put it in the budget as
adequacy we would just carry it on the
Surplus statement as an appropriation
adjustment that we know is coming okay
yeah
okay so where does that go
79 here snap I see it
otherwise I see it yeah
so just if you're keeping score at home
if the 75 million comes out and now
we're gonna Reserve 30 million for this
that's a net 45 essentially so that
bottom bottom line I'll change the
spreadsheet for the next time we meet
uh we had heard from the Department of
Transportation that they felt the lapse
estimates in the governor's budget and
the highway fund were a little high so
they had provided what they feel would
be a revenue estimates that they are a
lapse estimates they'd be comfortable
with that could possibly come up today
when when you have them in if you wanted
to bring that up after the house bill
two sections
uh row 81 so I added this on here uh to
reflect the house Ways and Means Revenue
estimates so as you know Highway block
grants apportionment a is paid to cities
and towns based on the prior years road
toll and motor vehicle fee is collected
so under the house Ways and Means
Revenue estimates fiscal 23 revenues for
Highway fun were 4.2 million dollars
higher
which means in fiscal 24 12 of that will
be paid out to cities and towns so we
just need to budget for that so you the
highway fund you picked up 4.2 million
dollars in your your total picture of
Revenue but we have to pay out 12 of
that or 504 000 in fiscal 24. so this
would be an increase to Dot's budget but
it's just passing through to cities and
towns
doesn't affect General funds
this this to me is somewhat of a
technical thing it's just yeah it's it's
to comply yeah exactly yeah
I think you can do that one today too
is that one the committee is good with
is that one is that your yeah okay so
I'll shade those out and record those
changes
that's that's about where
where we're at
um
I do have the fish and game fund and the
highway fund Surplus statements on here
but they're really not that different
than the last time we we met and
okay
foreign
there is a bill associated with it so
this is section
oh it's an hb2 sections 86 through 88
on page 32
about writing a Civics book yeah
yes
they were born in your town
it's sections 86 through 88 of um HB of
hb2 right
or anything
like
I will just say that personally you know
given the broad representation of the
people on the commission
I would be in support of that at the end
of the day Civics it's basic stuff it's
remind you know teaching
just the basic facts about how
government works and everything to me
that's not something I would object to
but of course if not everybody is ready
to discuss it yet we can wait until we
have the full membership available and
all that but I I personally am looking
at it and I'm reading the language and I
just don't see anything there that I
would see as uh
you know a lightning rod for something
yeah
most history books
kind of give short shrift in New
Hampshire and within the within the
history of our country it has played a
very important role both in the
Revolutionary War both in the Civil War
we we sent 21 regiments to the Civil War
we had a lot of people we lost from this
state it as a matter of fact
at the time we went from
family cemeteries to you'll see Union
cemeteries all over you'll be driving
through any little town Union Cemetery
why is it a Union Cemetery because they
fought for the Union
and they many of them were young people
that hadn't developed a family plot yet
so they all of a sudden these towns all
had to create Union cemeteries for all
the people that got killed in the Civil
War that didn't have a family plot and
you know people don't realize that the
importance that this state play Live
Free or Die and all this stuff that they
don't teach that if you buy a regular
history book they won't even mention New
Hampshire one of the 13 colonies
this isn't this isn't a history book
it's sort of a Civics book so there's a
difference between the History part of
it and the Civics part of it and um how
happy to look more into it but I do have
a problem of the legislature getting
very involved in state curriculum and if
it's a history book that's one thing but
that's not the same thing necessarily as
a Civics book and Civics is taught in
history it's taught in literature it's
taught in philosophy it can it be taught
anywhere so who's you know honing it
down is kind of a problem to me to say
that this is what Civics is going to be
and then the other part I get a little
concerned is that I can see going
forward someone's going to say who's
going to evaluate that this is the right
Civics book from the legislature and
again taking away that freedom of
education for teachers who are teaching
Civics in their classes in their you
know within the confines of what they're
doing they're teaching the left-wing
version
which is is not you just said history is
history destroying our culture you just
said history is history and no it is not
well there's the left-wing version
I don't know
so that section as well as other
education related sections I do plan on
having doe come in because they did give
some late budget changes they want plus
I think hearing from them on a lot of
these House Bill 2 sections will be
helpful so a day next week I haven't
figured it out yet we'll we'll have them
back
so you want to do lunch
all right we have somebody that won uh
dot at one and safety schedule to come
see us around two okay and in my mind
we're going to be out here by three
awesome
and I will say
today I will say we we still are in
budget work session this afternoon right
so as we roll through items with the
Departments if you're good with them and
you want to just check them off your
list and show our hands is good we can
do that
foreign
Transportation here and prepared to walk
through House Bill 2 sections relative
to their Department all right
uh good afternoon thank you for having
me for the record I'm Bill Cass
commissioner for the dot with me are
Andre Briere our Deputy Commissioner and
uh Danielle Chandra nay our Director of
Finance
um you should be able to help me with
any questions if
I can't answer them so
I think the first section would be uh
119 on page 43.
so if it would help I can just uh step
through them one by one and give our
rationale for the requests so
um
so our first request has to do with the
um appeals board
and what we want to do is um
eliminate the rail appeals board enroll
their functions into the transportation
appeals board the rail appeals board has
not met for many years historically it's
been difficult to find Qualified
individuals with real experience to fill
those positions
so I think by removing that and
enrolling their responsibilities under
the overall Transportation appeals board
will be more more efficient and easier
to just manage one appeals board so with
that under 119
um
uh calls for uh again some changes in
the um compensation I mean in the
composition of the of the um
of the uh of the Transportation appeals
Board number 120
um
just there you know just kind of
modifies
um modifies the uh duties of the of the
um transportation appeals board and
um number 121 is a repeal of the section
that eliminates the rail appeals board
okay
any questions from the committee
all all those who would support this
please raise your hand
okay
so the next item from the Department
um is number
uh
I'm gonna get my correspondence here
so
um
one of the things that we uh are
proposing with this is the establishment
of a revolving fund for the uh oversized
overweight permit fees we have a system
that
oversized overweight permitting
um there are some fees that that go into
that and support it right now we
maintain the system out of our existing
operational budget if there are any
additional fees
um they they just kind of lapse to the
highway fund what we would propose here
is to establish a revolving fund so that
the permit fees that that we get can can
be kept and carried forward to uh for
the maintenance the overall maintenance
of the of the system
and allow us rather than depending on
the operational budget allowing us at
that resource because as we go forward
it's a relatively new system but there's
annual maintenance cost and um down the
road there will likely be upgrades and
um
just um
uh keeping up with with software
requirements and stuff so this would by
by putting into a revolving fund would
provide the
um
means to keep it a self-supporting
system
bushes
about how much money goes through this
fund
um do you happen to know Danielle I
apologize I don't know off the top of my
head but I can get you that answer
representative Weiler
sure
um yeah I would Hazard to guess it's not
millions of dollars I think it might be
you know ten tens of thousands of maybe
a hundred thousand dollars but I that's
a speculation don't don't quote me
but it's not I know it's not Millions
it's it's a it's um
I'm remembering it being fairly minor
money yeah so but I'm just curious as to
anyway
I apologize I don't have that answer any
other questions
all committee members or support this
action oh
I I I apologize I I meant to
um I meant to note that
um we do have one minor change to the
wording
of this let me see if I have it here
and it has to do with um
and I I don't know if I I can I can pass
these around if you want but one of the
things that uh the way it reads now
it reads in that first statement
um hereby established an over length
over width and over height uh revolving
fund we want to add to that description
overweight
so it would read establish an over
length over width over height and
overweight revolving fund it's a little
Clarity of of the language because it's
you we typically refer to as the
oversized overweight program and after
we submitted this and rereading it
realized that it didn't necessarily
reference the overweight but that's a
big part of our program yeah I can draft
that probably if the committee is good
with that I can draft that and I have
copies of that change but it is what I
kind of read okay
about the overweight can we charge them
more
that hurts our roads too it does and
that's why we have the we have those um
fees established thank you yeah through
rulemaking right
okay with with the amendment uh
everybody in favor
okay
um so moving on
um our our third item has been number
um
it's the same it's the same word
reference yeah yeah
this should be added to there as well
too yeah yeah I'm sorry yeah I rolled
those together but they both refer to
the same
and they should both read the same
thank you for that
so moving on to our third item uh number
124.
um
this is um
adding an exemption to allow Highway
surveillance on the little Bay bridges
in Dover and Newington for security
purposes it was really kind of a it's
not really an extension but it's kind of
a um
uh a clarification to me what what is uh
existing
um
being
actively worked on in in the piscatica
river so working with the homeland
security and others we monitor for
security purposes the the major bridges
over the piscataqua river
um including the the little Bay Bridges
um
uh for whatever reason that has never
been part of the statute but it's part
of the practice uh working with Homeland
Security in the Coast Guard and others
so we wanted to clarify and and make
sure that our practices met what what
was in statute questions from the
community here
thank you um is that just authorization
or is there a fee attached to that it's
just authorization thank you yes
other questions
members of the committee in favor of
this item
okay
the next item number our number four
which is number 125
um
deals with um Prime Wetland designation
so the purpose of this request of change
is to specify that uh defined Wetlands
or their adjacent buffers
are not within the state highway rights
of way an Associated permanent easements
so this this change we look at is
clarifying that the department does not
need to adhere to these stricter Wetland
requirements for Prime Wetlands when
performing on normal Highway Maintenance
along State Highway right-of-ways
this change has been part of other
um other pieces of legislation dealing
with Wetlands definitions
um
this has been
generally supported but it hasn't been
passed because of other issues with some
of the delineations and some of the
other controversy with some of the other
um
Wetland statutes and changes that were
going on but right now Prime wetlands
are are not necessarily based on the
function and value they're more of a
political type of designation that
afford them greater
greater protection
it has been problematic on some of our
projects when when Prime Wetland when it
when a community had defines a prime
Wetland that that does reach into
um
uh the nhdot right-of-way
um because without it it does
theoretically limit what we can do in
maintaining our ditches maintaining the
normal right-of-way so
um this would be a kind of a
clarification or an exemption of that
that Prime Wetland designation within
the highway right-of-way
of course yes
I am I'm looking at that thank you for
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking the questions in reading the
language I find it hard to understand
exactly what it does you know because I
could really do say that you cannot
touch Prime Wetlands that are in a right
or away or that Prime Wetlands shouldn't
be considered you know
so which is the intent to allow you to
continue using your con existing
easements regardless of whether some
part of that becomes a you know
designated as a prime Wetland or not or
is it to say that you cannot touch prime
lens even though you may have an
easement on them already I genuinely I'm
not sure what the language is meant to
say the language is meant to exempt
the prime Wetland designation within
within
State Highway right-of-way
so the state highway right-of-way would
would Trump an override and the prime
Wetland designation would not extend
into the highway right-of-way I I
honestly just speaking for myself for
myself I would welcome a clarification
because the statute has already did I
find confusing personally it could
reflect my lack of legislative
experience here but
you know I could read it both ways you
know that we are not allowed to touch
wetlands and if we had an easement and
now something is designated as a wetland
you cannot put it in the Eastman so
something that would just clarify the
intent of this you know if everybody
else on the committee feels with help I
would strongly
support because I as I said I find the
text confusing thank you a clarification
of of what our proposed language is is
that what you find confusing yes I find
the current proposed language in hb2
really is hard to understand and it's
not clear to me whether it goes one way
or the other
yeah I'd like you to have you describe
for me what would this change and how
you're doing your work now you know what
are you doing now that you can't do or
that you would be able to do or
um you know can you give an example of
where
you haven't been able to do what you
wanted to do and if this passed how
would that impact the wetlands does that
make sense sure so um for example
um if if if if if we have a a ditch line
or the outlet of a culvert that is
within the that is within the
right-of-way and and it leads into a you
know bigger outlet and the community has
designated that that whole
um
Wetland complex as a prime Wetland then
without getting
um
Conservation Commission approval or
wetlander permits or things like that we
technically could not maintain the end
of that pipe because of the Prime
Wetland designation
so if you get the
the go-ahead from conservation then you
could do that
isn't there some value to having your
work organized so that it does protect
the wetlands
we would still we would still follow the
Wetland the Wetland rules if it is a
wetland within the within the state
right-of-way it's it's the uh a little
bit of the onerousness of the Prime
Wetlands designation that that um
that that places within the highway
right-of-way that can be
um problematic to us
so conservation commissions are not
overly friendly on this topic I wouldn't
say they're not overly friendly but it's
but it's a it's it's it's it's
um it's much more processed and much
more
um
um Administration and everything for us
to do that routine maintenance sure
thank you
so in light of that
is this going to drive bad press
in terms of that we're bypassing the
environmental steps that we should be
taking are we going to upset people with
these actions no I don't believe so
because like I said I know we have
worked closely with um
uh Department of Environmental Services
and and others who support this and and
recognize the
um
recognize the um
oils of of of the existing Prime Wetland
designations and I can get some and and
I don't know what we have I don't know
if we provide at the governor's office
but if it would help the committee I can
provide a uh in writing a a better
explanation with some support from Des
as far as what the implications are if
it would help you
okay
okay so you want to move on the story
we'll wait
I would suggest waiting just to get the
clarification because I think that based
on the clarification we require I would
still probably ask for a clarification
in the language of the law okay you know
just to make sure we really capture the
intent
so all right
moving along okay
so that brings us to number
um
five of ours which is number 126 here
which deals with um
agreements for telecommission
telecommunications related uses of our
state highway system and state-owned
railroad right-of-way so this is really
just a clarification of statutory
references the statute applies to both
Highway right-of-way and state-owned
right of and state-owned railroad rights
of way the existing language in in
statute only refers to RSA for colon 40
which refers to Railroad right-of-way
this just provides a clarification to
include RSA for 39c which pertains to
Highway right-of-way
questions from the committee no it's not
really a village
yeah okay question sure I remember at
one point when they were arguing about
the high lines coming down from uh Hydro
Quebec and people said well rather than
run it that way why don't you run along
the highway
and someone from the highway department
said no you can't use our right-of-way
for running power lines is that still in
existence
um
there are a couple of things that it
that had that had happened uh along with
that one of the things that did happen
legislatively was the designation of of
some um
uh utility or infrastructure corridors
um
uh which included like one-on-one in the
interstate highway so that legislation
that was passed makes that easier to
utilize those corridors for power
transmission or other things so it's
it's less restrictive than it used to be
I mean one of the one of the
restrictions was uh was within the was
within the limited access right-of-way
of an interstate highway and when they
were looking at
um
from the power line Transmissions they
were looking at State highways where it
isn't as restricted and they were
looking along like Route 116 and Route 1
and Route three uh they were going to
bury it is we're going to bury it right
um
yeah
but establishing those infrastructure
corridors and allowing it within the
within the need to stay right of YTM to
make a lot more sense for everybody it
never came in the northern path you read
this as a change and maybe an
improvement yes thank you you're welcome
any other questions
all committee members in favor of this
item
just question can we make sure because
on the sheet here we've got 125 126 and
127 together and 125 we have questions
on but 126 and 27th I think I'm sure
Mickey's on top of that
but they were lumped together as right
of ways and I'd pull out 125s right
okay
128.
yes you're right I'm sorry I'm with you
five and six were were relative to the
same thing right or or or 126 is 127
were the same so I've got to skip one so
um
yes this um this change just mainly
allows us uh enables the payments by
credit card uh and to charge a fee for
credit card payments
um for
um
for aircraft registration right now that
we don't have the authority to accept
payment for aircraft registration by
credit cards it's a little outdated so
it's a it allows us to do that and
charge the credit card fee along with it
so any questions
committee members in favor
okay
so 129
deals with Turnpike system uh toll
criteria and uh really this seeks to
clarify the statute to that provides a
discount to New Hampshire tolls for New
Hampshire Easy Pass customers
um we want to bake this amendment to
specify that in order to be eligible for
the discounted New Hampshire tolls uh
the Easy Pass account holder must be
using a funded New Hampshire Easy Pass
account and a properly mounted and
working transponder when a transponder
is not working or is not properly
mounted it requires Easy Pass to rely on
a plate read and cost us more to collect
um
tolls via plate reads and it's been
challenged with some of our things so
there's a lot of people that have like
transponders and Easy Pass we call them
the Easy Pass wave you know they take it
out of the glove box and and wave it
under the under the windshield as they
go through and it may or may not get a
read if it doesn't get a read
um and we have to go to a a toll I mean
a license plate read
um we don't give them the discount
because it costs more to look up the
read so this is
um you know just clarifying that and
statute that it really needs to be
properly mounted
in order to get the discount questions
yeah I can attest to that because I got
scolded by DMV for having my orange one
in the wrong place oh okay
yes
I just go to Sim if you will uh
which plate does it read
either either place we depend on both oh
you're Dependable thank you
there was a bill if you're referring to
there was a bill with a friend fun back
uh uh we we try to take pictures of both
if one's obscured it gives more um
it gets it gives more chances of getting
a correct read to have both the front
and the back so we we do both so that's
a real issue here when you're thinking
about snow and mud that you know
certainly your front plate could be
obscured for six months of the year
possibly so that's so it's a good thing
for you to want to have both the front
the back in case one is obscured yes
exactly
any other questions on this item
all members of the committee in favor
okay
and the final one with us uh is number
130 which deals with the State
Transportation Improvement program
um what we're proposing here is to amend
RSA 228.99 which which um which governs
our step process
to Institute and provide a 60-day
deadline for Metropolitan planning
organizations to review and approve
amendments to Transportation Improvement
plans this deadline will help us realize
other timelines set by state and federal
law to achieve more timely and
consistent planning results
what we find with our step amendments we
deal with several when when we're up
there in the step is our
governing document for
um you know construction projects and
stuff that are that are in their
construction project has to be funded in
a in a in a approved step to be eligible
for federal funds
um
it's very Dynamic we're always updating
keeping it current to the current costs
um we found it very challenging without
a uh harder deadline uh dealing with the
the different mpos and trying to get
this done in a timely fashion so this is
our our this is our our intent uh here
is is to um
get a more efficient
um stiff amendment process so that we
can keep things on track
great
questions from the committee
all in favor of this item
okay
I have a question in general by all
means I'm sure you'd love that general
question certainly yeah probably right
right on the tip of his tongue we saw a
piece where we were putting more money
into the uh
the state apart a you know distributed
to the towns and cities and because of
the revenue supposedly was up
the one we had reported from Ways and
Means was up over what the governor
thought which is highly unusual usually
the governor's estimates are above what
ways and means are so year over year how
is the highway fund doing in the in
collections
um I can't speak to collections
department of safety is in charge of its
collections so they can talk about the
revenue estimates and stuff but with but
relative to the um if you're talking to
was it SB 270 270 those are just about
about that there is presently a um I
think at the end of uh part of the Kappa
there was 111 million dollar Surplus
Highway fund Surplus part with that was
due to
um a 50 million dollar infusion of of
General funds into the highway fund that
would took place
um by the Senate at the end of the last
uh session and that was done in in
reflection of the structural deficit of
the highway fund um right right now and
and we're looking at it without just
looking at Mickey here beforehand that
uh at the end of this biennium that
present balance in the highway fund gets
spent down to
um you know close to I think 13 million
dollars so and we hope that there is a
structural deficit essentially
expenditures and Appropriations from the
highway fund out outstrip
revenues revenues coming in
roughly by about 28 to 30 million
dollars uh annually so you know that
current balance because of what the
Senate did at the end of the last
session is intended to at least carry
through this biennium
some good news thank you you're welcome
any other questions for committee
thank you for coming okay well thank you
for having us sure it's a pleasure
thanks so we just got one follow-up on
that yes I'll get that information and
I'll get it um to you Mr chair okay get
it to Mickey perfect
yeah I'm a disaster don't give it to me
you're gonna be seeing a another fiscal
item in the next physical meeting we
just rushed one through as we got
through last week and crunched all the
numbers on on on Monday of where we
stand with uh things
yeah
right right
it's probably about average to passes
this has been a very average winter it's
kind of come late but it's but it's
a general average yeah
yes yes
and no I mean we have and I I don't want
to take your time we can come I can come
away from the mic
but um
I probably said that we we are we are
staffed for summer summer maintenance
we've always relied on higher I Applause
to other states
um
live laptop and staff
with the maintenance
so uh we traditionally have not
staff but the forward domain relied on
the I I
vacancy rates this year by more heavily
on the market Cloud so that's open up
the bank but I wouldn't
want you to give away
we've never
had a full staff or major maintenance
now they've said that
I appreciate it
thank you
chipping away yeah
minimums but it's a lot of money coming
into school district and it's to help
kids participated and then all our other
clients are equally based on these
formulas they come out of Washington
based on that data so it means a lot
that we have put it up
but in some place actually
no no no no
that's the the current values are for a
family of four it's uh 27 750 in 2022
income numbers that's why we apply the
multipliers and we say 200 or
750 for a family of four
well that multiplied by 5 would be about
135. for a family of four
right and for a family for individual is
13.6 and for a family of uh eighties
forty six thousands
23 000.
yes
so the ones that we have right now it's
taken 300. so for new peoples for me no
it's
my understanding is that basically they
are looking to relax those income caps
for certain groups that are deemed to be
you know more decent right but you know
it's not the full huh
there's
pictures
let's see
good deal to me
yeah right yes so on on the busy
schedule the spreadsheet it's on the
second page so row 64. under the
retained bills section
s
among the students
and so it's kind of
they have
a special class kids come to uh it
worked really well I thought the number
of kids
um
get good results and it actually
originated
and this was one of the
ways that they identified as possibly a
source of building kids skills and a lot
of it is that it is attrition time for a
lot of people a lot of people
so this is kind of a public pressure
is that a fault to school district
I mean you know realistically I mean we
we've been talking about this for a long
remedial in the cause of levels for a
long time
practical applications like the kids
were achieve the parallels too
is
Gladys
insurance
takes three days to get us done
it's 200 000 I mean it's in our budget
we had it it worked well it went away
um because we had a boyfriend
initiator is definitely
a lot of money we have to express is
just
amazing
um
so what priorities do you put on
them
that's good I'll go on
well I mean you know it does but you
know you got so much money
you know you got your shopping list
90 million dollars you got to make it up
somehow
oh
look at him
not spending
you look like a kitty jar
it's way too much money
twenty thousand dollars a student
what are they spending parochial schools
after
easily
and if they close what happens
then and now they cost twice
okay
good job
that I've known for years
so that's 82 percent
and that's how many Charities
I remember visiting one where they said
those three students and IEPs for
emotional upset
they came to our school they were no
longer emotionally upset
I saved a lot of money
that's good
remember I was at the department of
Edward we developed charts
Middle School I remember that favorite
school it took me 10 years to pass
church and
I was with
um Lionel
that's a great program yeah
and it's fabulous and it's made a
difference to all people false teachers
I remember his name
he was he was a teacher
foreign
dealing with the associates degree
to dual enrollment
through the U.S
um
all kinds of Hands-On
forces that they've developed with
curriculum is our new development
teachers they know but they have over
ten thousand students
he said
no he said I enjoyed this morning
each
individually
it's a model of the United States and
what it's done is every single one of
the students at Temple High School she
was Barbara from Watkins in Paris
and she couldn't continue to go to high
school so she signed up with ux and she
graduated the same doctorate class so we
ought to put more money and relax and
Russian
so
ten thousand how about
how many students no no about about what
what they what we spend for relaxing
well remember dating they're here
so they did a mathematical equation
as well and so you're getting about one
course fraction so that's what the state
reimburses how much how much load can
they get
and they take six courses uh
more teachers no no but I mean what what
you know I think
as many as they can because
they have staff that works with the
students so that if they're taking too
many of them
um just like in regular store with kids
off on me likes don't always compete
um you have to be a certain kind of kid
that's really self-directed to really do
well and some kids build and some things
um you know it's new I think it couldn't
college kids it wouldn't stand being
online
what I love is like a virtual
environment that's happening here
part of the time you see the kids
but they didn't have different
assignments
people tend to actually internships
okay
it was interesting you didn't have all
the reagencies don't give a chemistry
lab so instead of there you go
what do you call witness tests
boil up cabbage
okay
it's a number
five it was my first time
thank you
foreign
you know what I can wait for a
thank you
it's pretty good
well we can go ahead and start the work
session
uh welcome
and you've obviously got it all written
out already so
it's your show
we'll just eat we're going to consider
each item as you present it okay very
good thank you um
so good afternoon Steve Lavoy director
of administration for the Department of
Safety
um with me as commissioner Quinn good
afternoon Robert Coyne commissioner
Department safety store so the items
that are listed here in order from
in-house Bill 2 so they're in the exact
order of the bill first is the body worn
and dashboard camera fund and this is an
item that appropriates an additional
million dollars one one million five
thousand dollars in Appropriations
um two fund grants to locals which are
to encourage them to adopt body camera
and Cruiser cameras in their police
departments
and these grants will cover costs up to
50 percent up to fifty thousand dollars
per entity and that program was designed
with those restraints to ensure that
both small and large
departments had an opportunity to
participate
to date we have funded
I believe it was 48
communities over over a million dollars
in in funding and so there's definitely
a demand out there for these types of
this type of financial support and this
is a small way that the state is able to
help encourage this adoption
questions from the committee
looking I was looking at this page which
started with
the police force cap and I'm trying to
find an hb2 the reference to
um the cameras which I'm
it's on page 32 of the bill
and it's like um
item number 81.
now I'm caught up thanks
Heather Thomas yes
so it's just one year so I it's not
elapsing right
correct yes it's a it's a non-lapsing
continuously appropriated fund which
allows us to continue to offer those
grants until the money uh is drawn down
and it seems like it's really working
well everywhere I know in Manchester our
guys are using them
um they seem to like them I think it's
accountability for everybody
thank you
and this just provides more
opportunities for others that might not
happen
okay
all members of the committee in favor of
this item
all right
all right the next item
um
it does two things one it establishes a
new grants program and then it also
provides the Appropriations to to fund
that and that's the northern border
Alliance program
um
that's the language that's on page 34.
uh
item number 93.
and so this program would make grants
available to State County and local law
enforcement agencies and also fund
um overtime patrols at State Police to
reduce the instance of crimes and
illicit activity and proximity to the
Canadian border
specifically within a 25-mile radius is
what has been identified there's 619
thousand dollars appropriated for New
Hampshire State Police and 815 000
appropriated to local County Partners in
that area it's modeled after an existing
federally funded grant program called
operation stone garden
the funding for that particular program
has has been reduced over the last
several years it was about 300 000 per
year over the last two Grant Cycles it
was reduced to a hundred and eighty
thousand dollars per year and there has
been increased activity in illegal
Crossings and so this is one way that we
can ensure that state laws aren't being
broken along along the Border
I think you had a question on this part
two do we have a problem with the Border
so I will tell you um
there
we have 58 miles of border
we fall between the Swanton and the
Holton section of the border patrol
um we are following activity uh through
our New Hampshire Intelligence and
Analysis Center there's open source
information but you what you will see is
in a full month period what what was
reported recently was I want to say
almost an 850 percent increase in
apprehensions of illegals in that
northern border area so recently I
believe it was an AP article that
indicated that the border patrol has
increased with 25 additional agents to
the northern Board of that area so I
think what we're trying to do is be
proactive and ensure that we have the um
the program and the collaborative
resources needed to to protect the
border so you've got
um just loving that part of New
Hampshire I think about I'm not going to
say the the lake oh my friend my GOG
that one
um that that's in Canada and New
Hampshire or Vermont actually
um and then there's a lot of
um
snowmobile trails how do you how can you
cover all that how will those offices do
that it isn't just border control it's
it's people coming through different
areas sure so that's a great question
and um what I learned recently is the
majority of that land is uh State Forest
when yes um so that's that's essentially
why this program was developed 10 years
ago so to do that what you need is a
plan so you need a plan built on enough
resources state and federal the state
and local offices can enforce local
state law the federal Offices can
enforce federal law but they have a
coordinated plan built on obviously
intelligence and so getting all the
federal Partners to work with the state
local that's how you do that through
land maybe sometimes air but but there's
uh it's a lot of work though
so a question I have is how will we
prevent
incidental stopping of individuals let's
say
um Hispanic era of color incidental
um I just want to make sure someone
doesn't get stopped just because they
don't look like everybody else in the
North Country sure sure no that's a
great question so I think it's important
to note that even um the state police we
have what's called a fair and impartial
policing policy which um is very clear
on
some of the areas that we want to
prevent there's a a carve out in there
that says what they can and can't do but
specifically to the border so you know
with you know car stops away from this
area they have to adhere to the fair and
impartial policing policy but what we're
talking about here specifically is is
the Border in areas of of Ingress in
that area so the the New Hampshire State
Police will be very very cognizant to
adhere to their policy all right thank
you
yeah
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
the questions
um I'm trying to understand because I'm
already aware of the uh you know lovable
100 mile border Zone under the federal
regulations that essentially allows CBP
to um
treat this area as if constitutional
rights don't really apply in the name of
securing the borders I'm genuinely
trying to understand if when we already
have an overreaching federal statute why
do we need to Grant even further
authority to our you know State you know
law enforcement to operate within a 25
you know mile border I'm not concerned
about the Appropriations I agree that
you have a job you know you have to be
given the resources I'm fine with the
program my question is specifically on
the
in additional Authority granted under
here which I'm trying to understand why
it's needed giving that again the CBP
already has you know the Customs and
Border Patrol already has a massive
amount of authority which I find
excessive in every every way so why do
we now need to add to that right so that
that's a great question and again I
think this is very limited
um in the scope of what the state
troopers would be added and again its
majority is a state forest but there are
specific
um authority to those
dncr officers and we're just in the
event that a State Trooper comes across
and they don't have the border patrol
agent with them and what's happened in
the past is you know these details were
really developed the program was to have
a partnership So what had happened in
years past was the border patrol agents
were shifted away from there and unable
to to go in partnership with the state
troopers all the fish and game officers
are the dncr are the Colebrook offices
so what we're doing with this is more to
I would just say make sure we minimize
any liability and that if they have to
take action and they're alone they have
the same Authority that the force and
land do in the event of somebody that
crosses over in those I appreciate the
explanation honestly you know I would
appreciate if the committee would
consider discussing the Appropriations
and the legislation separately because
my vote will be different on the two
topics you know so uh either way
thank you
yeah thank you do we have one Border
Crossing in New Hampshire up at the
Connecticut Lakes
or how many border crossings do we have
we have the poor the the animals in
Pittsburgh and that's from eight
a to 8p right
and this is pertaining to
um the work you do on the highway on
roads no so is this because I'm what I'm
asking is there any problem with people
there'd be nuts to try to cross through
that forest and if you got across you
wouldn't be anywhere in Canada you'd be
miles from you'd be at least 12 miles
from a house
well and I think ma'am if um if you look
at what's happening in that area that's
exactly what is happening with those
Crossings and what we're trying to just
stay proactive on but there's two issues
here like um director of The Voice said
we are in close proximity to that border
but there's really you know we know
there's some roads you know we've got
Route 3 we've got other areas so this
this program is focused on the border
but there can be you know going out in
the out in the rural areas on the
off-road vehicles but again it's all
driven by you know what do we have for
intelligence working with our federal
partners and expanding this to make sure
we uh we understand why what might be
happening you know where we should be
where we should be focusing but again
it's 58 miles of border and um if
anything is you know on the roads it's
in that general area or it's focused
narrowly on the border
sure great thank you Mr chairman uh
thanks for being here
um
on that same border crossing okay you
said it was open from a certain time to
a certain time and if you come up is it
still open in other words if you let's
say you come after after hours I believe
the gates just closed oh the gaseous
closed because I know in the past you
could just drive across and then you had
to report say the beach of Falls and you
know I think the number is open source
last year don't don't hold me to this
but I I believe I read there was like 7
500 passenger vehicle vehicles that went
through and 1500 commercials so that's a
year that was yeah that was in a year
that's cool the other thing I wanted to
to make note of is the pro the one of
the main reasons behind this the stone
garden program that director Lavoy
really spoke of which was built and
established which was trying to enhance
it
um we have limited funds
so we have limited Appropriations to
continue to to really pay attention to
what we believe is going to be an issue
and have the funds available with this
to ensure that we have enough Law
Enforcement Officers out there we know
what will be coordinated we've got
strong Partnerships with with uh with
the Border Patrol and um so it's going
to be important for us to have the funds
necessary to put these uh these folks
strategically out there to to secure
this area
yeah don't follow well I I do have
follow-up uh I know I've talked to
officer uh state state police up there
and it's a very big area to cover and
they didn't have very many people to do
it I I we don't want to get into numbers
because that's that's something else but
I know that uh in the past it's been a
tough
tough to enforce yeah any any law
enforcement yeah and and our our you
know the colonel the state police The
Troop commander of the troop F area
um if these funds are given we will you
know we will establish a good program
built upon stone garden I know we'll
have uh uh have a lot of participation
um there's a lot of good Folks up there
on Fish and Game and dncr and the local
police departments that will work
together and I think we will enhance and
and be out there and do our best to be
proactive it I I do think it is
something that um that we we have to
focus on if you just look at the data if
you look at what's happening in close
proximity
um it says that we need to be you know
forward-leaning as it may shift
question thank you Mr chair what would
you do with the people you apprehend
um will you believe are not citizens of
the United States yeah so so that's a
good question so we're not federal
agents but what would happen was the
border patrol agents would take them
into the Beecher Falls section where
they would process them per their
protocol
and there won't be any stopping of buses
and checking people's passports or
well yeah and again there there has been
a lot of discussion on on checkpoints
that have taken place further south but
that is not what we are discussing with
this program and um this program is
focused on the border and if we enhance
and we have the other opportunities this
gives us is enhance equipment we might
need whether it's more four by fours to
go off Woods radio equipment that might
be needed if we need to make sure they
can transfer they can talk
interoperability so just to have them
out where they need to be and obviously
with any of this um there'd be a
training component I've worked closely
with the Attorney General's office and
to make sure that prior to getting this
up and running that we have a training
and they have they've agreed to
coordinate that get all of the offices
together ensure that we have a solid
understanding of state law federal law
just I'm sure things have done the right
way
oh so you're you're looking for drugs
coming into the state
um weapons coming into the state
illegally uh uh people who have
um been maybe arrested someplace you
know I don't know I just want to make
sure it's it's respectful
but um because didn't we have during 9
11 weren't people some people came down
through Canada came down from Canada
into I don't know if it was New
Hampshire but ultimately they got to
Boston it would seem like they went
through New Hampshire to get there
um I just want to make sure that that
the people that were apprehending are
the right people to apprehend absolutely
it's respectful yes okay thank you and
you're going to come back and tell us
all about what your plan is
absolutely okay thank you
okay yeah I'm just curious
um you know this I grew up on the border
in Newport and
um
is there still any kind of a you know as
a as a hiker as a hunter you just go
back and forth across the border because
that's where the hiking trails went
because that's where the deer went is
that still um you know is there still
will the Canadians come down for hunting
do we go across the border because I
mean it's not well it's just kind of I I
will tell you I I had um I know that
when they go out and do these patrols
sometimes that happens that people are
just you know they make a mistake
they're going back and forth and I know
that they they deal with that
educationally you know making sure it's
just yes so I mean when you get out
there I have never done those patrols
you know I don't know that area but I
think you know having the right people
that are trained to encounter anything
and you know quite honestly
um there's a uh there's a a medical
component of this making sure that if
somebody you know needs medical
assistance so that they've been hiking
they're out in the cold weather they
recently had one which has been
published uh a Mexican individual across
from Canada and to Vermont and and died
and so you know the weather up there
it's harsh and
especially the weather yes sir
but the training component is is
important we're not just I think that
you know we will we will enhance what we
have with stone garden but ensure that
we have the right training from the
Attorney General's office and guidance
okay
dad did you have an issue with this
as I said I'm fine with the
Appropriations I do not plan to support
the uh you know changes in the you know
authorities I I have full confidence by
the way in the intent of the police you
know of the law enforcement to use them
appropriately
is just given the existing state of the
federal laws and everything that aren't
absurd overreach I just cannot support
an extension of that regardless of how
much more highly I think of our you know
state law enforcement versus the federal
so if we could
well the federal thing already has such
a huge amount of authority within a
hundred miles that I just cannot support
another extension to you know the 25
miles for us it's
they already have the CBP and I hear you
that sometimes the CBP is not there but
the CBB can already do anything they
want within 100 miles I just you know
this is not no and I just to clarify
this is not giving the federal no no I I
understand I I completely understand it
as I said it's it's just
I I'll be happy to talk offline I don't
want to take a lot of committee time
right now on it because I don't
understand
supporting the money without
the fund they seem to be pretty much
tied together what would they do with
the money I think no no I'm fine with a
fund there is just a portion of the
legal language that expands the
authority to stop people right and
that's the part of the time objection
objecting to here it is but it doesn't
apply to this because this is just a
board this is not 25 miles this is yeah
page 35 the very bottom
have the same Authority and powers
granted to forest rangers and official
of the vision of Forestry and lands
that's that's all I mean everything else
and please understand it I approve of
the effort I agree with your goals I
just feel that there is already enough
legal authority to be able to do that
job without that being needed
so you're uncomfortable with the
Department of Safety having the same
Powers as forest rangers
correct I believe that in this
around the borders constitutional rights
have been thoroughly abused by the
federal agencies and I believe that at
this point in time there is plenty of
authority now if that 100 miles Zone
from the CBP would be eliminated I would
very happily agree to Grant those rights
but I believe that there are enough
legal you know authorizations in place
that more are not needed regardless of
the different agencies involved
so this came in hb2
would this have been something that you
wanted in the department of safety or is
it because the governor put it in hb2 no
I think no we we would want this just to
ensure that if our state troopers are
out there and they come across somebody
Crossing into this land that's spawned
by the state forest that they could take
the same action that the State Forest
officers could do
say it was a fishing game and State
Forest wasn't the fishing game and a
State Trooper or Colebrook uh that
that's all we're just looking forward to
reduce any liability if we have this
fishing game officers they have a lot of
authority
and I can't speak specifically to if
they have this Authority this just says
for us so okay thank you yes okay
all those in favor of this item
appropriation yes language three five to
two
I accepted
all right
yeah it's me and Mary who are the two
okay here so um the next item is on page
52 it's item number 148. and what this
does is it eliminates the existing
statutory cap for hiring auxiliary State
Police which are part-time Troopers
is currently limited to 16 individuals
this eliminates the number from statute
and puts the Restriction within our our
operating budget so if the funds are
available we can hire the the Troopers
if the funds are not available we cannot
okay questions to the committee
all those in favor
the next item which is also page 52 item
um
in summary this has to do with the fire
fund fees so these are fees that are
collected for motor vehicle records
primarily insurance companies collect
this data there are some other
authorized users as well
the fees are set by Statute currently
this would eliminate the fees from
statute but add the requirement that the
department set fees through
administrative rulemaking instead and
what that does is it allows the
department to
um
greater flexibility to increase fees
when needed to ensure the operations can
continue
questions from the committee
just there's still a lot of
accountability though because you still
have to go through gel car and the whole
rulemaking Authority so
it still won't process it's still a long
process we will have to go through rule
making
um we we would have to go through an
expedited version of that because of the
timing of this change so that we could
still charge fees as of July 1. thank
you but that process does exist through
that through through jail card other
questions
okay all the members are coming in favor
of this item
okay unanimous
the next item uh is 150 on the same page
uh this is related to those fees and the
entities who are allowed to utilize the
driving history records
this language allows
um Federal entities in certain instances
to utilize these records in the same way
that a commercial entity would like an
insurance company or some other
authorized agent these this change is
required based on our estimates to
ensure that we do have enough Revenue
collected from the fees to support both
fire safety and fire standards and
training
questions from the committee I'm just
trying to understand how does this
change allow you to achieve that goal
are you planning to basically sell the
data to the federal you know government
just like you would to a commercial
entity correct correct so the language
prohibits the federal government from
establishing databases using this data
um
and so this would allow the federal
government to utilize the data in the
same way as as a corporate entity would
so they would have access to it but
couldn't
um couldn't use it to create a a
database
I appreciate the clarification I don't
really trust the federal government's
willingness to abide by that but given
that we anyway give it to a commercial
entity the feds could buy from there
anyway so you know I'll leave with this
thank you
for years
okay any other questions
all members of the committee are in
favor of this item
okay
all right moving on to page three of the
handout
uh
so this item in House Bill 2 which is on
page 53.
so House Bill 2 this transfers the
requirement to make one annual
unannounced inspection of licensed
facilities from Health and Human
Services to the fire marshal in
discussing this with HHS we realize that
there are two levels of authority that
HHS have to provide inspections the one
that we'd like to transfer is later in
the bill this particular one we don't
want to transfer and HHS does not want
to transfer and so we're asking that
this amendment be struck but this
amendment not be voted forward HHS is an
agreement to this there are implications
to CMS that I don't understand entirely
but they've shared with us saying this
could be a problem and they have the
resources to do it item number 151 on
page 53.
I'm just getting clarification so in the
end who's going to do the fire
inspections
so Health and Human Services will be
responsible for all of their for
inspecting all these facilities and they
work in conjunction with the Fire
Marshal's Office
and so this original thing was to move
the fire thing under your jurisdiction
but you're happy that it stays at HHS
we're both in agreement it should stay
there there's another component of
inspections related to plans for
construction new
um new construction and enhancements and
then initial inspections of those plans
which we'll talk about later which
should still move thanks okay so the
vote is to strike strike this item all
those in favor
yay one item gone
all right the next item is
number 152 on page 53.
and this establishes a program assistant
to within the division of fire safety
and appropriates the funds to support
that position to perform fire code
Amendment
um
updates and postings as required by a
law that was passed last session it was
Senate Bill 443 and at the very end of
the that legislative session and that
bill it was realized that this position
was inadvertently left out of of the
bill when we were asked to add it back
in during the budget process and so
that's what this language would do
question from the committee
all those in favor of this item
okay
the next item
um it's actually both item 153 and 154
and these have to do with authorizations
related to our positions of the
Department of Safety the first allows us
to fill unfunded positions so long as
we're using the budgeted funds in class
10 so we can't go over our budget and
the second would allow us to establish
full-time uh temporary class 59
positions if somebody is on extended
military leave and just establishing
that position through administrative
services in that case without having to
go through the existing process which
requires fiscal committee approval
okay questions to committee
all those in favor of this item
okay
153 154.
right next item is 155 on page 53 and
this is appropriating funds to this
existing substance abuse enforcement
program and this is a program that
supports additional narcotics
investigations activities at State
Police as well as grants to locals and
it's utilizing data-driven intelligence
to help combat the narcotics problem
opioids and others as well
289 000 is appropriate to State Police
narcotics investigations unit 119
000 is appropriated to the forensic lab
when they're doing the analysis on
seizures and then uh 1.6 1.7 million is
appropriated for Grants to locals also
included in those Amounts is the five
percent
um that's required by RSA 604
A1 dash C to transfer to the judicial
Council for any Grant activities that
are generally funded that could increase
the
arrests and then the need for Indigent
defense and so that's included Within
These Appropriations
questions I hope you're doing some work
in Manchester
we work very closely with Chief
altenberg because we really have a
problem
all you have to do is walk down the
street it's everywhere it's crisis
levels
thank you
Joshua funds
General funds
thank you
um one of the items is for you know
funding overtime at the State Police for
enforcement and investigations
obviously you know you have a backlog of
cases you gotta you know have over time
but
generally it is more effective under
most situations to just you know have
another full-time equivalent and uh you
know pay them at the normal rate is this
one of those situations where overtime
is needed and if so why do we do over
time instead of just a you know
full-time position or a part-time
position that's a good that's a great
question so these really are um they're
really unique positions they're
Specialties so those men and women
assigned to the narcotics Investigation
Unit have had some Advanced Training
um there they could be undercover
operatives uh they're trained in you
know surveillance techniques and um so
it really is giving them the funds those
specific individuals to continue to work
these cases which a lot of times just go
beyond a normal you know eight hour day
and so there really isn't like a you
know a second shift that can come in and
cut it thank you
other questions
yeah I was sorting out which how much
money goes where can you speak to the
effectiveness of granite Shield
um you hear you know back and forth that
it's effective you hear that it's not
effective can you um speak to that
so I would say I have asked that
question didn't ask that question many
times and
um to not give to give an opinion what I
would say is this I think it's important
to point out that based on the efforts
of granite Shield those officers that
are working across the state
collaboratively in two in FY 22 what
they removed what came in in fentanyl
equated to what the lab says is 673
000 potential fatal doses
and through 12 31 22 they removed 528
000 potential fatal doses so those went
from the street
to the police officer to the crime lab
so in and of itself it's hard to
quantify or predict what that's saved
but that in and of itself shows that um
that that is effective in removing
dangerous drugs
so that I think that's the best evidence
I can
bring forward
there's a lot of work to that too to
seize these drugs there's surveillance
there's undercover buys at times there's
you know applications of search warrants
it's a lot of work to put a case from
start to finish and then and then done
safely you know they work very hard out
there
other questions
all members of the committee in favor of
this item
yeah okay
the next item
is on page
54 item 156. it's
and what this does is
it authorizes the administration of
naloxone for an if an individual is um
show signs of an over of a drug overdose
from fentanyl or heroin
it authorizes that Administration
without a license so currently
if you're an emergency response
professional you're required to be
licensed on naloxone Administration
there are some police officers who are
and there are some who aren't and this
would allow those who aren't to respond
in a situation like that instead of have
forcing them to wait for someone else
who's license to come forward and it
treats I'm sorry if I recall correctly
and I'm sure you know way more about the
topic naloxone is available you know to
regular people
and it is deemed generally to be safe to
administer even if that wasn't a drug
overdose but it can be a lifesaver so
it's kind of a huge upside but very
little if any downside in using so I'm
kind of questioning why we need that
license to start with to be fair but I
have no problem with the you know this
language that would allow life-saving
drugs to be administered without waiting
for somebody who carries a piece of
paper there so thank you
other questions
okay members of committee in favor of
this item
okay
the next item is on page 54 158
um what this item does is it amends RSA
153 to authorize employee organizations
to establish peer support groups that
are confidential so right now an
employee organization can establish a
peer support group but there's no
confidentiality under the law if an
individual goes in to that group as
opposed to if they go to the employer
established peer support group we're
talking about emergency response
Professionals in that that industry and
what we know is that individuals are
less likely to seek peer support uh if
it's not comfortable it's not
confidential
questions for the board
where in Norwich in hb2 is that that is
Page 54 item number 158.
oh thank you
other questions
is this just for state workers or
everybody no I think I think it's
important to know to authorize employee
organizations so if there's an
organization that they can establish and
have the same confidentiality we're just
looking to ex to make sure that they
expand a form or something say that I
will keep all proceedings confidential
yeah there's there's training that's
required for that organization to
operate as a peer support unit thank you
thank you
foreign
okay
any other questions
committee members in favor of this item
please raise your hand
all right
okay the next item page 56 159
um
this suspends
rsa99b2 which is a statute that limits
the percentage of Highway fund
allocations
um that the department of safety can
utilize over the biennium and there's
some question as to whether we even need
to expect suspend this particular
I was very proud of the fact I passed
this to Control Commission of Flynn
who one year went out and bought 567
2001 crowd Crown Victorious
because he thought the guys like that
they're not making them anymore
and most of them you probably remember
some have sat in the field
for years
and and it said where do you get this
Authority so and the dot would come to
us he's taken all our money
so it took me a while to pass this but
this was my solution
having some of this unbridled he also
went to a display of fire equipment
brand new fire engines
and he witnessed it he said to the
manufacturers when they got through what
are you going to do with these I guess
we'll put them up for sale what kind of
deal can you give me he didn't have an
appropriation for that but he bought him
put him in the fire academy
so it was it was times that he felt like
we felt like he was going
uncontrolled nobody dared do anything
so I put in this 26 percent the highway
department was very happy about it
because obviously safety collects the
money
Highway doesn't know how much money you
collected until you give them what what
you what they feel what you feel like
so
there was a conflict here
is it do you think you're going to spend
more than 26 percent
so I'd turn it over to LDA on that one
so safety and Dot are bound by what you
appropriate there's no kind of open
checkbook so to speak or blank check for
either Department there is the authority
to come to fiscal that's the only uh
option they've got what we'll do is make
sure that the budget that you pass is
compliant with RSA 99b and if not the
suspension could remain but as of right
now and as it came out of the governor's
office it's compliant so this suspension
is not really needed right now if
depending on the decisions this
committee makes it becomes relevant we
can discuss that then but I think
I'll continue to monitor the work that
the committee does and and if that's
needed we'll include it if not we'll
delete it
sir you lost me
Well for now just I think you can just
ignore it ignore it for now because it
would be contingent upon budgetary
decisions this committee makes moving
forward
I think we may have in other budgets
exceeded it
we have had budgets where it was
exceeded and the suspension was required
about six years ago it was Rewritten if
you recall
betterment is a dedicated part of the
road toll that just goes to Dot and the
4.2 Cent increase is a dedicated portion
of road toll that only goes to dot those
allocations didn't used to be part of
this calculation we changed the law so
they would be and when that happened the
necessity for the suspension has kind of
gone away because those funds were 100
to dot but they weren't really reflected
in that calculation but now they are I
think that's
okay
all right the next item page 57 item 161
this is an appropriation
[Music]
um
no I'm sorry I skipped one
Cody oh
160 yep page 56 160. just keep doing it
so this is a cyber security grant
program this is a Homeland Security
Federal grant funded program
multi-year multi-million dollars to
improve cyber security in the state
um we have brought an item forward to
fiscal and GNC recently for 2.4 million
and these are the matching fund
requirements that for FY 14 and FY fy14
FY 24 and fy25 based on what we expect
to receive from the federal government
um these are yes these would be General
funded
questions from the committee
that what's in favor of this item
oh
what it will do you have to fraud
um just cyber bad things happening
um yes all of that so bad guys out so so
there's a there's a cyber security
um group uh
is it the planning committee
um and so that's chaired by uh our CIO
commissioner Dennis Goulet we've got
representation from local government on
there public safety Public Health it's
really looking at the state local and
County government systems in New
Hampshire and one helping to train and
educate the individuals responsible for
those and two working on other
collaborative ways that we can increase
cyber security across our networks and
our systems to prevent
large-scale issues from shutting things
down you hear about ransomware you hear
about small towns who now can't function
because their systems have been they've
been locked out of their systems so it's
it's a multi multi-year multi-faceted
approach to cyber security for
government
just very briefly more of a statement
it's
it's a place where smaller governmental
entities have a hard time getting the
expertise to deal with this so having
something at the state level to provide
proper guidelines and Equipment can be
very very effective and beneficial so I
think it's a good idea to you know
provide those resources
we're all on the committee in favor of
this item
okay
speaking of cars
not quite as many as representative
Wilder just mentioned but the Chairman's
favorite
Topic's a good car they don't make them
anymore
foreign
yes yeah so so this item which is page
57 161 this appropriates 3.5 million
dollars to purchase 52 Cruisers and we
spoke about this one a little bit in our
budget presentation we do have uh 70
vehicles in uh year one and I believe
it's 72 in year two in our operating
budget these are additional one-time
purchases to resolve the fact that over
the last several biennium because of
budgetary constraints we didn't have
Appropriations to fulfill our
replacement plan and we also had
challenges in purchasing vehicles for
the Appropriations that we did have
because of supply chain issues so the
these additional purchases will help to
resolve the health issues and the state
police Fleet moving forward and allow us
to come forward in future biennium with
with more regular and stable maintenance
and repair and replacement requests
okay yeah thank you these are
specialized cars and so I'm curious what
do you do with the old cars that these
will replace
so the old cars get um Surplus through
the white Farm all of the
um uh so the state that's the State
Surplus process so it goes through
administrative services and they operate
a um they operate a surplus auction
um two times a year and these vehicles
are auctioned off the monies that um are
earned from those sales go back to the
funds that they were purchased with so
if we purchase the vehicle with Highway
funds the sale money goes back to the
highway fund
that's right
question source of funds
uh this is General funds
Mickey here
this is already in the governor's yeah
to confirm this is already accounted for
in the governor's yeah past budget or
the governor's recommended budget
yeah
okay
we didn't vote this one yet
oh all in favor
okay
okay and then
last but not least this is page 78 item
225 health facility licensing inspection
so this goes back to the item that we
asked to be struck from house bill to
um
both HHS and fire safety agree we do
want to transfer this Authority for new
construction or facility alteration plan
review inspection and approval from HHS
to the Fire Marshal's Office so this is
a function that was performed at HHS
with two full-time positions but they
struggled to train and hire people
because it's not really their line of
business and it made sense to bring this
Into the Fire Marshal's Office where
they have Engineers who already
performed this function for other state
buildings and state agencies the key to
this particular
language is and I and I provided you an
updated version of our prioritized needs
listing the very first item there are
the two positions that would be required
in order for this transfer to occur yeah
are the position can be transferred from
DHHS to you no the positions were
abolished by DHHS so they reduced their
budget by this dollar amount which we
coordinated with them on okay um
but in essence we're picking it up yes
yep but we do need to establish these
positions
um in order for this to transfer
um hb2 it's page four of the of the
handout page four
oh hp2 page I'm sorry page 78
item 225 health facility licensing
inspection
and I'll clarify for the committee this
is not on our working index so which is
maybe why you don't see it in our
document this was a division three
assigned section but it is related to
what uh okay what we're talking about
here so assuming division three keeps it
in these positions should be considered
by us all right
other questions
yes so who's been doing the inspections
HHS has but they didn't have any people
to do it well I I I don't want to say
there there wasn't anyone in the role so
maybe delay they had struggles in
filling both positions at all times and
so that caused delays in the program and
you you're going to be able to find
people uh we we expect to because we are
able to we have other individuals who
are
um uh engineers and are able to perform
that work so if there's delays in hiring
we could have someone else step in and
help with those thank you
no these are group one
and we've coordinated with the fire
marshal Sean Toomey who's an engineer
who oversees this so he's well aware
that this is coming
no you have to push it
okay all in favor of this item please
wish your hand all right
to confirm Mr chair is that the item in
House Bill 2 with the corresponding
positions yes okay so the we would
change this in house bill one and I
would add those positions to that
accounting unit okay
at least that's my understanding
that that certainly is the request I
just want to make sure everyone in the
committee is aware of the kind of a
two-step uh
approval there okay thank you thank you
thank you very much
if if you read what what's being
reported there's a lot of activity from
Canada which you're attempting to
come into either Vermont or Upstate New
York that's what focuses on the northern
border our section of 58 miles what
we're trying to do is secure that but do
you think
I I couldn't speak to that sir
well the Swanton sector covers those
West and they also support us on a
stretch so everybody
thank you
congratulations
I think that does it for today yeah we I
don't think we have any new business or
any additional business we can cover I
can tell you for Friday I'll uh I'll
update these documents and everything
we've made some progress today which was
good uh 10 o'clock Friday we've got the
two EFA bills right off the bat and then
at 10 15 I've got scheduled another
budget work session uh and like I said
I'm still trying to coordinate
to see if we can hear from doe on
anything I know they've kind of got a
some folks not around Friday so we may
have to push a bulk of the deal we work
to next week and like I said I still
have a request into the governor's
office to see if I can coordinate
someone to come talk to us about the
changes to the unique program and the
student debt relief the 529 thing we
refer to so perhaps we can get some
folks in Friday to talk to us about that
too okay
what what do we have going Friday
afternoon I think
so let me asking
prevention
approximately yeah
generally
yeah it's a section so page 20 to 27
sections 52 to 61.
foreign
if I may add a chairman Weiler mentioned
this a couple of times you know on the
house floor already early you know it's
basically a if you have an interest in
the budget talk to us early enough when
we can maybe do something about it don't
come that's all it's just an Outreach to
the rest of the house and uh you know
today
even though they've worked on they never
support it even when we give you what
you want you don't support it
and Republicans do
because
he walks away
you're gonna have money for schools to
have money for projects but you'll vote
against the budget
would you hate me that's probably true
yeah those kids
you should treat all students
on that on that border item if you you
know there are three items in it that I
voted